Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt.
Mein Name ist Tim Prittlaff und ich begrüße euch hier nach einer längeren Pause im Programm zur 145.
Ausgabe. Und heute wollen wir uns mal wieder dem Krieg in der Ukraine und auch
ein bisschen dem Konflikt zwischen den USA und Iran widmen,
aber vor allem die Berichterstattung über die Ukraine fortführen.
Und dazu begrüße ich natürlich Pavel. Hallo Pavel.
Hallo Tim.
Genau, letzte Sendung hatte ich ja mit Enno gemacht, der wie so oft mal wieder in der Ukraine war,
glaube mittlerweile sogar as we speak auch schon wieder zu einer neuen Reise
dorthin aufgebrochen ist.
Und haben über seine Erfahrungen vor Ort gesprochen,
wie er die Gesamtsituation so einschätzt, eine kurze Zusammenfassung gemacht,
aber dann auch so ein bisschen über den Iran-Konflikt gesprochen und über die
Eröffnung seines Museums.
Das kann ich euch nur ans Herz legen, falls ihr da noch nicht reingehört habt.
Ja, kann ich auch nur empfehlen. War super. Vor allem das mit dem Museum fand
ich halt wirklich interessant.
Und auch, ja, wie denn so die deutschen Behörden im Vergleich zu beispielsweise
den Niederlanden mit Ukraine-Artefakten umgehen und so,
das doch sehr bezeichnend.
Und die Starlink-Geschichte war irgendwie auch, ja.
Wir sollten da mal hingehen, Pavel, zusammen.
Ja, genau. Aber heute wollen wir jetzt erstmal ein bisschen die Geschichtsschreibung hier fortführen.
Und wir knüpfen ein wenig an unsere letzte Sendung an.
Bevor wir das tun, wollten wir aber nochmal einen kurzen Blick auf das Geschehen im Iran werfen.
Wollen wir jetzt nicht so im Detail drüber gehen, ihr werdet das ja alle mehr
oder weniger mitbekommen haben, dass eigentlich nichts passiert.
Also es passieren natürlich am laufenden Meter Dinge und ich meine,
als wir das letzte Mal drüber berichtet haben, war dieser ganze Konflikt erst
so zwei, drei Wochen alt.
Und ja, da haben wir schon ein wenig die Position eingenommen,
dass das nicht so einfach werden wird für die USA, weil der Iran die USA so
ein bisschen bei den Eiern hat durch die Besetzung der Straße von Hormuz und
jetzt sind schon Monate vergangen.
Habe ich überhaupt zum Datum gesagt? Wir nehmen auf am 1. Juni,
Also wir blicken jetzt quasi auf den April und den Mai und noch so einen halben
März zurück und in diesen zweieinhalb Monaten ist eigentlich nicht wirklich
irgendwas vorangegangen. Also es gab diverse...
Scheinverhandlungen würde ich das mal nennen, in irgendeiner Form vermittelt
immer durch Pakistan, da kam aber nie so richtig was bei raus,
da ist dann irgendwie J.D.
Vance mit Bagage angereist und dann sind sie nach einem Tag schon wieder abgereist
und es geht die ganze Zeit hin und her und wie das eben so ist mit Trump,
es wird einfach im Wesentlichen so alles nur über soziale Medien geführt,
Dann werden immer irgendwelche Maßnahmen angekündigt,
die dann so nicht stattfinden,
womit sich wieder alle Hoffnungen machen und die Aktienmärkte reagieren und
die Prediction-Märkte reagieren und dann stellt sich dann später immer raus,
dass irgendjemand ganz viel Geld damit verdient hat, dadurch,
dass diese Ankündigung da etwas bewegt hat.
Da kann man mal drüber mutmaßen, wer davon wohl so profitieren mag.
Auf jeden Fall ist es ein ewiges Hin und Her.
Die Straße von Hormuz ist de facto immer noch blockiert. Die USA hat ihre eigene
Blockade nachgeschoben, um sozusagen die vom Iran durchgelassenen Irantanker dann noch abzufangen.
Was, wenn ich das richtig sehe, nur so begrenzt funktioniert.
Die Situation für die Golfstaaten wird nicht besser und spitzt sich teilweise zu.
Und da es halt auch immer mal wieder ein Aufflammen von Angriffen gibt.
Durch so Maßnahmen, dass die USA dann mal versuchen irgendwie durchzubrechen
und dann gibt es aber wieder irgendwelche Gegenschläge und ja,
das bedeutet einfach, dass in zunehmendem Maße die Infrastruktur dort leidet,
entweder weil sie nicht mehr gepflegt werden kann oder weil sie aktiv durch
Angriffe zerstört wird.
Zum Beispiel ist im Iran, durch den Iran wurde schon ein signifikanter Teil,
ich habe so 17% gehört der LNG,
also Liquid Natural Gas Infrastruktur in Katar zerstört worden.
Es gab ja auch diverse Angriffe auf Entsalzungsanlagen etc. Und das sind halt
alles so die Lifelines für die Golfstaaten.
Und die Welt kriegt halt nach wie vor keinen Nachschub. Also es mögen ein paar
Öltanker nach China noch durchkommen.
Aber im Wesentlichen ist Asien stark unterversorgt. Das hat in manchen Ländern
auch schon erhebliche Auswirkungen.
Also vor allem die, die nicht China sind. Weil es gibt kein Öl,
es gibt kein Gas, es gibt kein frisches Helium, es gibt keinen Dünger,
es gibt keinen Schwefel für die chemische Industrie.
Und ja, das wird nicht mehr lange dauern, denke ich. Und die Auswirkungen werden
dann auch irgendwann mal in Europa zu spüren sein.
Ja, ich meine, es gab zwischenzeitlich ja, es gab unglaublich viel Drama.
Gerade was so Trump natürlich angeht,
Also es wurde erst mal fünf Wochen lang, wie wir das in etwa auch vorhergesagt
hatten, wurde halt bombardiert von USA und Israel.
So das war das Ding.
Und dann gab es halt dieses immer wieder Waffenstillstand hin und her.
Waffenstillstand, ja, nein.
Nein, dann war irgendwann das Drama, dass dann Trump sagte, ja,
NATO kommt zur Hilfe und dann haben ihm aber die gesamten europäischen NATO-Staaten
erstmal den Finger gezeigt, so nach dem Motto, was willst du eigentlich?
NATO ist ein defensives Bündnis und du hast uns vorher auch gar nicht gefragt.
Das war dann viel hin und her und dann meinte Trump, ja, das war nur ein Bluff,
ich brauche euch ja gar nicht, das war jetzt nur ein Trick, um rauszukriegen,
wie ihr denn so drauf seid.
Und naja, also das war jedenfalls ein unglaubliches Hin und Her,
bis es dann eben zu diesem Slow-Fire kam und dann Trump mehrfach auch gedroht
hat mit einer kompletten Vernichtung Irans.
Also dann dort sozusagen Iran in die Steinzeit zurückbomben wollte und dann
dachte ich, na gut, dann schiebe ich das jetzt nochmal um ein paar Tage auf,
das Bomben und ein absolutes Hin und Her,
was dann irgendwie in diesem Ceasefire oder eher auch, manche haben es eher
Slowfire dann genannt, weil es ja erstmal lange weiter ging.
Und natürlich Israel in dem Ganzen auch noch massiv rumgemischt hat und dann eben Libanon.
Ja, für ziemlich viel Verwüstung gesorgt hat,
aber gleichzeitig dann auch das erste Mal mit Fiber-Optik-Drones auch an dieser
Stelle konfrontiert wurde.
Genauso wie die Amerikaner dann plötzlich feststellen mussten,
dass neue Waffen und Waffensysteme da sind, mit denen sie halt nicht so gut klarkommen.
Und die Amerikaner eben jede Menge teure Stand-off-Munition verschossen haben.
Also erst mal eben Tomahawk-Missiles, aber auch Mengen an Abwehrraketen und so.
Also da sind für wahrscheinlich, ja...
Fünf bis zehn Milliarden US-Dollar alleine Munition ist dort verschossen.
Es waren sowohl offensiv als auch defensiv Munition.
Und die USA hat erhebliche Verluste auch an Luftfahrzeugen und Infrastruktur
in Militärbasen und so schwer beschädigt.
Und insbesondere, was ich bemerkenswert fand, wo halt wenig drüber geredet wird, ist.
Wie viele von den teuren amerikanischen MQ-9 Reaper Drones und anderen super
teuren Drohnen abgeschossen wurden.
Also es sind jetzt wahrscheinlich irgendwo in der Größenordnung von 40 Drohnen
und die Dinger kosten so Stückpreis 30 Millionen.
Also es ist schon Größenordnung, also da kriegst du auch schon gebrauchte F-16
ganz gut für oder auch ein Drittel des Preises von einer F-35 Kampfflugzeug.
Aber manche dieser Drohnen waren halt auch mit superteurem Kram ausgestattet
und kosten wohl bis zu 400 Millionen.
Also ein oder zwei von diesen superteuren Drohnen wurden dann auch abgeschossen.
Und ich fand das halt sehr bemerkenswert, ja, wie wenig überlebensfähig diese
Drohnen dann offensichtlich sind.
Klar, die nutzen die dann natürlich auch mit wesentlich höherem Risiko,
aber im Vergleich zu Kampfflugzeugen und so, ja, werden diese Drohnen in Massen runtergeholt.
Du hast natürlich dann auch quasi dagegen gespricht, dass die Luftabwehr des
Iran ausgeschaltet wurde.
Und das galt halt dann immer nur temporär und für bestimmte Zonen,
wo man dann reingeflogen ist,
aber so umfassend, wie das den Anschein machte, dass die Kontrolle des Luftraums durch die, oder ja,
Luftherrschaft, ja, aber nicht wirklich. Also nicht diese 100 Prozent,
von denen immer die Rede war, sondern,
Zu bestimmten Zeiten unter bestimmten Bedingungen konnte man die Luftabwehr unterdrücken.
Aber es ist nicht so, dass im Moment amerikanische Luftfahrzeuge über dem Iran
einfach gefahrlos spazieren, fliegen können.
Das ist definitiv nicht der Fall.
Ja.
Ja, dann gab es ja noch dieses Drama zwischendurch mit dem abgeschossenen Piloten,
der dann irgendwie zwei Tage da irgendwo im Iran sich versteckt hat,
was auch dann eine super teure Rettungsaktion nach sich zog,
bei der dann auch noch zwei Transportflugzeuge und zwei von den kleinen Hubschraubern
verloren gegangen sind von den Special Forces,
was halt Problem hat, dass sie nicht mehr gebaut werden im Moment,
beziehungsweise immer nur batchweise bestellt werden können.
Also das Ganze hat an verschiedenen Stellen doch das Arsenal an Munition, was die USA hat,
doch nennenswert gelehrt und aber auch überhaupt Verschleiß und so weiter.
Man rechnet, dass wahrscheinlich die Kosten, wenn man jetzt die höheren Ölpreise
außen vor lässt und nur guckt, was denn das Militär das Ganze gekostet hat,
sind wir in der Größenordnung von 100 Milliarden alleine, die das Militär dort
jetzt aufgewendet hat, die nicht im Budget enthalten sind.
Ja, weswegen jetzt auch dann fürs nächste Jahr Trump gerne den Militäraushalt
nochmal um 50 Prozent auf 1500 Milliarden erhöhen möchte,
was halt absolut krass ist und was ich mir aber auch nicht vorstellen kann,
dass er damit durchkommt.
Genau und überher musste er lernen, dass er mit einigen nicht so durchkommt.
Also er war ja irgendwie total hyped von dieser Aktion in Venezuela und das
hat wohl dann maßlos dazu beigetragen, dass er also die Herausforderungen,
die jetzt ein Iran an ihn stellt,
total unterschätzt hat und sich da eben von Netanjahu hat quasi überreden lassen,
in so ein Abenteuer reinzugehen.
Und jetzt haben sie halt echte Schwierigkeiten, das auch in der Öffentlichkeit
in irgendeiner Form positiv darzustellen, weil es wird kein gutes Ende nehmen.
Jetzt ist es halt so, dass die Situation schlimmer ist als vorher.
Also vorher war der Iran, gar keine Frage, eine Bedrohung der Sicherheit,
aber mittlerweile ist halt nicht nur der komplette Welthandel mit dem Golf zum Erliegen gekommen.
Nein, wir haben jetzt auch noch das Problem, dass mehrere Golfstaaten eigentlich
ihrer Lebensgrundlage entzogen werden,
weil einfach ihr gesamtes Gesellschaftsmodell selbst hier nicht nur auf dem
Prüfstand steht, sondern eigentlich leidet.
Also wer es sich leisten kann, dürfte diese Regionen schon weitgehend verlassen haben.
Also Leute, die da in irgendeiner Form aktiv waren und die jetzt quasi täglich
damit rechnen müssen, dass wieder Kämpfe ausbrechen und die jetzt nicht unbedingt
auf diese Gegend angewiesen sind.
Die werden sich anders orientieren, Touristen ohnehin.
Und damit hat Trump halt auch das Selbstverständnis und das Gesellschaftskonzept
dieser Länder stark bedroht.
Ja und wie geht es da jetzt weiter, wissen wir nicht. Also im Prinzip geht es
immer hin und her, es wird immer irgendwas angekündigt und irgendwas in Aussicht
gestellt, aber Trump hatte einfach kein Drohmittel mehr.
Weil nochmal so all in zu gehen, ist halt erstmal nicht bezahlbar,
aus den schon genannten Gründen.
Also allein das, was es jetzt schon gekostet hat, ist vollkommen unklar,
ob diese Mittel überhaupt noch zu holen sind. Man bräuchte sie eben auch dringend,
um überhaupt erstmal das Arsenal wieder aufzufüllen, was halt jetzt bedrohlich reduziert ist.
Also diese permanente Wehrhaftigkeit an allen Fronten der USA,
die ist halt nicht gegeben.
Einen Flugzeugträger musste man jetzt auch endlich mal wieder nach Hause schicken,
weil die jetzt irgendwie schon seit einem anderthalb Jahr durchgehend auf den Weltmeeren rumeiern.
Und solange hält so ein Flugzeugträger das nicht aus, da gingen dann irgendwie die Klos nicht mehr.
Und das ist aber mal jetzt nicht unbedingt so der Zustand.
Und da war die Wäscherei ja auch noch, ist Wäscherei brand, sodass dann irgendwie
500 Mann auf dem Flur schlafen mussten,
weil ihre Kabinen alle verraucht waren und so und die Klos funktionieren halt
nicht, weil irgendwie das, ja.
Kein Spaß auf jeden Fall. Und naja, das heißt,
dieses Selbstverständnis der Amerikaner, dass sie quasi in der Lage sind,
jederzeit überall mit Übermacht einzufallen, ihren Willen durchzusetzen und
mehr oder weniger unlimitierte Ressourcen zu haben, das bröckelt halt jetzt einfach extrem.
Und du hast es ja auch schon angesprochen, sehr viele ihrer Systeme konnten abgeschossen werden.
Sie haben jetzt nicht so die hohen personellen Verluste, bei so einem Distanzkrieg
auch nicht sehr überraschend, aber es sind halt fast alle ihre Militärbasen
im Golf, mussten sie zurücklassen,
weil sie die nicht ordentlich verteidigen konnten gegen einen Drohnenkrieg,
gegen den sie nicht gewappnet sind.
Und lustigerweise ist halt das einzige Land, was wirklich da eine Lösung anbieten kann, die Ukraine.
Wo Trump natürlich sich nicht zu schade war, da öffentlich immer wieder zu behaupten,
man bräuchte das ja nicht, aber unter der Hand sind natürlich da jetzt schon
Deals eingeführt worden, weil natürlich das Militär gesagt hat,
Leute, ich bin nicht mehr.
Das explodiert uns alles hier unterm Arsch, wenn wir nicht von der Ukraine Interceptor-Drohnen
hier installieren und UAE und Saudi-Arabien, Bahrain.
Katar, diese jetzt so hochgradig getroffenen und betroffenen Länder und Kuwait,
die haben halt jetzt alle Verträge mit der Ukraine abgeschlossen,
beziehungsweise dort sogar direkt in die Militärindustrie rein investiert.
Geld haben sie ja noch eine ganze Menge und das hilft natürlich jetzt der Ukraine
doppelt, weil sie natürlich auf der einen Seite Kohle bekommen für die Weiterentwicklung
ihrer Technologie, wo sie ja sowieso schon sehr schnell dabei sind,
aber vor allem auch dieser ganze Mythos mit die Ukraine hat ja nichts.
Ja, das weicht jetzt doch stark auf und dann werden wir jetzt auch gleich nochmal
im Kontext des eigentlichen Ukraine-Kriegs nochmal drüber reden,
aber das ist jetzt einfach mal ganz anders.
Jetzt steht die Ukraine da und allen Militärs der Welt ist jetzt klar geworden
oder sollte jetzt klar geworden sein,
dass erstens der Krieg, der moderne Krieg sich jetzt geändert hat durch diesen Krieg in der Ukraine,
dass auch die ganze NATO und alle modernen Armeen vielleicht mal mit Ausnahme
von China darauf nicht vorbereitet sind, Dass sie nicht die richtigen Waffentechniken haben,
dass sie nicht die richtigen Strategien und Ausbildungen haben.
Wir hatten ja auch in einer der letzten Sendungen mal über dieses Manöver berichtet,
wo dann so eine kleine Drohnengruppe von Ukrainern dabei war in so einem simulierten
Scharmützel und quasi allen NATO-Truppen dann mit ein paar Leuten das Material
unter dem Arsch weggebombt hat.
Und ja, das führt natürlich auch dazu, dass die Ukraine anders gesehen wird
von der Welt, also zumindest von dieser Regierungswelt und das ist sicherlich nicht zum Nachteil.
Es gab jetzt noch eine zweite Militärübung dieser Art.
Das zum einen und dann zu dem, ja, ich glaube, mindestens mit zehn Staaten hat
die Ukraine jetzt irgendwelche Drohnendeals geschlossen.
Mit der USA wohl ist der große Drohnendeal immer noch nicht unter Dach und Fach,
habe ich irgendwie gestern gehört.
Also Selenskyj schrieb davon irgendwie, dass er gerne irgendwie diesen Deal
schließen kann, aber es gibt da wohl irgendwelche,
ich vermute mal, dass die USA ja irgendwie gerne alles haben möchte für umsonst.
Und exklusiv wahrscheinlich. Und ich vermute mal, dass es da irgendwo,
also ja, es gibt jedenfalls noch Unstimmigkeiten,
vielleicht auch, weil Trump irgendwie oder, weil es da irgendwo gegen Feuer gibt.
Ich weiß es nicht, ist halt ein bisschen unklar. Was die Golfstaaten noch angeht.
Und speziell Saudi-Arabien gab es da ein Ereignis, das erwähnenswert ist.
Und zwar hat Trump den saudischen Kronprinzen Bin Salman halt massiv beleidigt.
So auf wo er dann auf einer Konferenz irgendwie dann behauptet hat, ich,
He didn't think he'd be kissing my ass über Salman gesagt.
Und Salman hat Leute schon für weniger umbringen lassen.
Und das kam wohl gar nicht gut an.
Und es gab dann wohl auch gewisse Reaktionen.
Über die aber gar nicht so richtig berichtet wurde, dass ja nämlich dann gewisse
Investitionen, die dann in den USA geplant waren,
dann abgesagt hat, aber mit der Begründung wegen zu geringer Einnahmen,
also hat das sozusagen mit wirtschaftlichen Problemen begründet,
warum jetzt die Investitionen nicht kommen.
Aber das kam halt dann sehr zeitnah in der Woche, nachdem Trump quasi diese
Beleidigung losgelassen hat.
Und irgendwelche Waffendeals standen dann plötzlich auf der Kippe.
Aber so ein bisschen unklar, gut, wahrscheinlich will oder kann,
soll man sich nicht leisten, jetzt einen offenen Bruch mit der USA.
Aber mein Gefühl ist, dass er am liebsten eigentlich sich ganz woanders hin
orientieren wollen würde,
wenn er denn könnte.
Und ja, also da bin ich gespannt, wohin das jetzt gehen wird mit Saudi-Arabien und in den.
Die Emiraten sind dann auch, glaube ich, erstmals Israelis, haben dann bei der
Luftabwehr geholfen, glaube ich.
Das war auch nochmal so ein spezielles Ding.
Und ja, aber im Moment scheint es völlig unklar zu sein, wer eigentlich was
will und wohin sich das orientiert.
Aber mehr und mehr Länder auch arrangieren sich jetzt bereits mit dem Iran,
was so Passage und Durchfahrt angeht.
Und das sieht schon ein bisschen so aus, dass es halt jetzt erst mal darauf
hinausläuft, dass wenn es zu irgendeiner Einigung kommt,
dass der Iran von irgendwo Geld verlangen wird.
Und haben wir auch schon entweder für die Reparationen, entweder Reparationen von den USA,
was ich schon ziemlich ausgeschlossen halte, dass man jetzt sagt,
naja, okay, wir haben euch jetzt alles zerbombt, wir bezahlen euch jetzt den Wiederaufbau.
Sondern für Trump und die USA wäre es dann unter rein transaktionell finanziellen
Gesichtspunkten viel billiger,
wenn welche Nationen auch immer, also die Asiaten, die da durchfahren sollen,
sondern Reparationen quasi an den Iran-Zahlen in Form von Straight-of-Hormuz.
Toll kann ich mir vorstellen, dass Trump damit sehr gut leben könnte,
jetzt von der finanziellen Seite her.
Aber ja, der Rest der Welt ist damit dann überhaupt nicht einverstanden,
dass die USA dort dann was zerbomben und sie dann quasi den Wiederaufbau bezahlen sollen.
Also, das wird interessant.
So Expertenmeinung ist auch, dass um so einen Waffenstillstandsstil oder vielleicht
noch mit oder ohne Atomfragen normalerweise mindestens,
wenn man wirklich knallhart verhandelt mit guten Profis und so.
Sechs bis zwölf Monate ungefähr ist so die typische Zeit, die man braucht,
die Profis mindestens brauchen, um die Details zu klären, damit das auch dann umsetzbar ist.
Also welche Kontrollmechanismen, welche Überwachungsmechanismen,
welche Sanktionsmechanismen und, und, und.
Also es ist halt schon ein komplexer internationaler Vertrag oder wenn irgendwelche
Rüstungskontrollen mit drin sind.
Ja, also und in dem Fall haben wir es aber offenbar nicht wirklich mit Profis zu tun,
die da auf Seiten der USA verhandeln in dem Bereich, sondern die halt elementare
Verständnisprobleme haben.
Ich meine, sie lernen so langsam, glaube ich, dazu.
Und es gibt auch Leute, die sich da auskennen natürlich in den USA.
Aber die haben sie anfangs, so saßen sie nur, wurden die entweder gar nicht
mitgenommen oder saßen nicht wirklich mit am Tisch oder durften nicht reden.
So und es ist eine totale Clown-Show.
Was die USA da abziehen und dieser Witkow und ja, die haben halt auch erstmal nicht verstanden ähm,
Was so den Atomdeal angeht, also das Thema Anreicherung beispielsweise,
so Trump dann immer, ja, nee.
Und Anreicherung war dann immer gleich, ja, wenn sie anreichern können,
dann können sie auch Bomben bauen und dann werden sie auch Bomben bauen.
Und wenn sie Bomben haben, dann werden sie Israel zerstört.
Das war irgendwie diese ganze Kette, so vier Schritte, die dann passieren, zwangsläufig.
Und deswegen darf Iran halt nicht anreichern.
Der Punkt ist nämlich erstmal nur mit, von der Anreicherung her,
der ursprüngliche Deal war, dass sie eben auch nur auf einen,
also der Obama-Deal, wie es so schön heißt,
mit Iran, war halt, dass sie irgendwie bis zweieinhalb oder drei Prozent anreichern
dürfen und das dann in ihren Atomkraftwerken,
ihre Atomkraftwerke damit zu betreiben.
Und ja, und davon wird Iran, wird definitiv nicht dahinter zurücktreten.
Sie haben auch das Recht dazu, im Übrigen, laut Atomwaffen, Sperrvertrag und so.
Mittlerweile sollten sie...
Jetzt ein bisschen besser Bescheid wissen, so die amerikanische Delegation,
denke ich mal, wenn sie jetzt da Stunden und Tage und Wochen lang drüber geredet haben,
werden sie, glaube ich, langsam begriffen haben, dort auch der Witkow und so,
werden jetzt wahrscheinlich schon tiefer im Problem drinstecken und das verstehen.
Das Problem ist nur, was offenbar mehrfach jetzt passiert ist,
sie haben sich geeinigt irgendwie in den Gesprächen, hatte man sich auf irgendwas verständigt,
dann ist die amerikanische Delegation zurückgekommen und Trump hat gesagt,
kommt überhaupt nicht in Frage.
Ja, so und so ging das halt permanent hin und her und dann hat Trump wieder
irgendwie behauptet, ja wir haben uns auf das und das geeinigt und dann der
Iran hat gesagt, das stimmt alles überhaupt nicht, wir haben uns auf gar nichts geeinigt und ja,
so geht das halt hin und her.
Ich meine, zeitweise haben ja beide Seiten sogar unterschiedliche Angaben darüber
gemacht, ob überhaupt verhandelt wird. Die Amerikaner meinten, wir verhandeln.
Iran meint, es gibt keine Verhandlungen.
Und dann wurde die USA gefragt, mit wem sie denn da verhandeln würden.
Ja, wissen wir jetzt auch nicht so genau, mit wem wir da jetzt gerade verhandeln.
Aber es scheinen die richtigen Leute zu sein, mit denen wir da verhandeln.
Also wirklich ein absurdes Kasperle-Theater.
Ja, also ich denke, dabei können wir es jetzt auch erstmal belassen,
weil es ist jetzt unklar, wie es hier weitergeht.
Also USA haben eigentlich den Kürzeren gezogen, sind natürlich nicht die Bohne
bereit, das in irgendeiner Form zuzugeben in der Öffentlichkeit,
suchen jetzt händeringend nach irgendwelchen Lösungen,
finden keine, weil es keine gibt, denn eigentlich müsste die USA...
Eigentlich müssten sie sagen, wir haben diesen Krieg verloren,
weil wir nicht nur nicht unsere Ziele erreicht haben und zwar keine,
sondern wir haben die Situation für uns und alle anderen auf dieser Welt schlimmer gemacht.
Und im Prinzip ist das ja jetzt schon ein völlig untragbarer Zustand,
weil natürlich hier sehr, sehr, sehr viele Staaten.
Also auch Deutschland, aber Deutschland nicht in demselben, also uns betrifft
es nicht in dem Maße, weil wir halt noch Reserven haben.
Aber das wird sich meiner Auffassung nach jetzt in den nächsten paar Monaten
dann auch verschlimmern, weil natürlich irgendwann die Auswirkungen auf die Chipproduktion.
Auf die Ernten und die damit verbundenen Konsequenzen, das wird in irgendeiner
Form auch auf uns zurückfallen.
Und natürlich sollte eigentlich der Druck auf die USA dementsprechend international
anwachsen, nur dass die USA halt derzeit halt einfach überhaupt nicht bereit
ist, auf irgendjemand in irgendeiner Form zu reagieren.
Kann es eigentlich nur sein, dass wenn solche Proteste nichts bewirken,
dass die Proteste quasi dadurch entstehen müssen, dass man eben Maßnahmen ergreift,
die die USA spüren und da wo sie nicht ohnehin das jetzt schon spüren durch
höhere Benzinpreise etc.
Und damit ja auch quasi höhere Transportkosten für all das Zeug, was sie importieren.
Also es wird ja eh alles teurer, aber noch können sie das in gewisser Hinsicht
wegstecken oder meinen das zumindest wegstecken zu können oder können zumindest
die Diskussion darüber noch flach halten.
Aber wenn jetzt halt Staaten wie Japan so weitermachen, wie sie jetzt schon auch angefangen haben,
dass sie halt nicht mehr diese ganzen Staatsanleihen nicht nur nicht neue kaufen,
sondern vielleicht auch bestehende weiterverkaufen.
Dann wird es halt teuer für die USA, sehr schnell und das ist sicherlich die Stellschraube,
mit dem man ihnen am meisten Beine machen kann, nur dass es halt,
und das ist halt das Problem, alle ja mehr oder weniger in einem Boot sind,
weil geht es den USA schlechter,
geht die Wirtschaft dort zurück.
Dann trifft es ja auch all die Unternehmen und die ganzen Staaten,
die halt den USA auch alles verkaufen.
Das ist ja das Dilemma, in dem sich zum Beispiel auch China ganz stark wiederfindet
und natürlich auch Europa.
Trotzdem denke ich, ist das eigentlich der einzige Weg, wie man hier noch in
irgendeiner Form Trump umdrehen kann.
Also ja, dazu ganz kurz,
also mittlerweile die Zinsen auf amerikanische Staatsanleihen sind mal wieder
auf einem absoluten Hoch, also irgendwie in 5% Territorium.
Das Ding ist, also die Situation ist nur ein bisschen komplexer, als man denkt.
Also erstmal schluckt aus dem Dollar raus, also ja, viele würden gerne aus dem Dollar rausgehen.
Problem ist, es gibt halt nicht so richtig Alternativen, also keine wirklich
Märkte, die Geld in dieser Menge aufnehmen können. Also Europa.
Naja, so, klar kann man ein bisschen nach Europa verlagern, aber das ist halt begrenzt so.
Wenn wir jetzt Staatsanleihen dort abziehen, muss das Geld halt irgendwo anlegen.
Keiner will sein Geld so richtig in China anlegen, so, aus Gründen natürlich,
oder in Russland oder in vielen anderen Ländern.
Japan, das ist noch so eine, aber also will sagen,
Auf der einen Seite ist der Dollar aufgrund des Mangels an Alternativen nicht
wirklich akut bedroht, aber.
Das andere Problem, in den letzten 40 Jahren,
wir hatten ja in den 70ern, gut viele waren dann noch nicht geboren,
aber da waren halt Zinsen extrem hoch.
Da hatten wir teilweise auch, also in UK gab es irgendwie Inflationsraten von 20, 30 Prozent.
Der Fund ist massiv gestürzt, aber generell auch in den USA.
Wir hatten Zinsen, da teilweise Inflationsraten 10, 20 Prozent in der Größenordnung.
Aber seitdem sah es so aus, hat man das mit der Geldstabilität einigermaßen im Griff,
in dem wann immer Dinge irgendwie teurer werden, wann immer die Zinsen oder.
So rum, wenn jetzt inflationäre Tendenzen da sind, dann erhöht die Zentralbank
die Zinsen, das kühlt die Wirtschaft ein bisschen ab, Zinsen gehen dadurch runter.
So funktioniert eigentlich dieser Kontrollmechanismus. Das Problem nur,
in dem die USA jetzt sitzen,
ist, dass die Staatsschulden so hoch sind und die wirtschaftliche Situation
so prekär, dass wenn jetzt die Zentralbank die Zinsen erhöhen würde auf einem Level,
wie es eigentlich notwendig wäre,
dann bricht der komplette US-Staatshaushalt zusammen.
Weil mittlerweile geben die USA so eine Billiarde, also 1000 Milliarden pro Jahr an Zinsen aus.
Also mehr als fürs Militär müssen sie im Moment an Zinsen bezahlen.
Wenn die Zinsen jetzt weiter ansteigen, aber auch nur um 20 oder 30 oder 50
Prozent, dann zerreißt das einfach komplett den US-Haushalt.
Weshalb dann die Zentralbank nicht so unabhängig ist, wie sie eigentlich sein
sollte, weil sie ja natürlich nicht die Wirtschaft zerstören wollen oder nicht
das Land zerstören wollen.
Das heißt, sie können jetzt auch nicht effektiv dem entgegenwirken.
Irgendwann weiß niemand so genau. Es sieht nicht so aus, als wenn das jetzt
in nächster Zeit explodieren wird.
Es sieht halt auch, wir betreten gerade wieder wirtschaftliches Neuland und niemand weiß,
wohin das wirklich führen wird gerade.
Ja, okay, lass uns mal den Teil zu Iran abschließen.
Ja, es gibt noch eine Sache, die sich vielleicht als Überleitung zur Ukraine ganz gut eignet,
weil in den Verhandlungen hat der Iran irgendwann die Ukraine angesprochen,
als es darum ging, um Garantien.
Im Gegenzug, also Verzicht auf Atomprogramm, hat dann der Iran gesagt, naja.
Die Ukraine hat ja ihre Atomwaffen abgegeben und ihr habt ihr auch im Budapester
Memorandum versprochen,
dass ihr die Ukraine beschützt und ihre territoriale Integrität uns so garantiert.
Und sie haben es gemacht und jetzt seht ihr, was irgendwie ihnen passiert ist.
Also wie wollen wir das Problem denn jetzt lösen, wenn offenbar ihr zu euren
Zusagen, was die Ukraine angeht, nicht gehalten habt?
Wie sollen wir euch da jetzt irgendwas glauben?
Das heißt, das war jetzt noch so ein interessantes Ding, Wobei die Situation
mit den Atomwaffen war komplexer, aber da brauchen wir jetzt nicht reingehen.
Fakt ist, dass die Iraner jetzt die Situation der Ukraine und die mangelnde
Unterstützung der Ukraine durch die USA jetzt in Verhandlungen als Argument vorgebracht haben.
Gut, dann wechseln wir mal auf das Geschehen in der Ukraine und wir wollen die
einzelnen Fortschritte dort mal im Detail vorstellen, wie wir das immer machen.
Ich fange aber mal mit einer kleinen Übersicht an, um jetzt an der Stelle mal
so schnell zu sagen, was ist eigentlich passiert.
Und um es knapp zusammenzufassen kann man sagen,
die russische Offensive, die jetzt im Prinzip so seit 18 Monaten so richtig
wieder mit Nachdruck von den Russen entwickelt wurde,
in dem sie einfach ohne Ende Personal nachgeschoben haben,
jegliches Militärgerät, was ihnen in irgendeiner Form zur Verfügung steht,
zum Einsatz gebracht haben und auf breiter Front überall vorgedrungen sind.
Vorstoß auf Kupiansk, weiterhin der Versuch über Bachmut hinaus,
Chassifjah in irgendeiner Form in den Donbass im Norden einzudringen,
aber schon auch mit Erfolgen an
diesem südlichen Teil dieses Verteidigungsgürtels der Ukraine im Donbass.
Also Konstantinivka ist da schon schwer unter Beschuss geraten.
Entziehen ist ja da die Gegend um Kramatorsk und Sloviansk, was die Russen nicht erreichen werden.
Und dann auch noch Fortschritte im Süden. Waren alles so, naja,
zahlenmäßig Fortschritte?
Aber militärisch eigentlich gar nicht. Also im Wesentlichen war Russland damit
jetzt beschäftigt, irgendwelche Felder einzunehmen und kleinere Dörfer.
Auch dieser Kampf um Pokrovsk ist halt zwar am Ende gelungen,
also man hat die Stadt dann erfolgreich eingenommen, im Sinne wahrscheinlich
von komplett zerstört, nur wenig darüber hinaus.
Und das war halt so eine Stadt, die vielleicht 30.000 Einwohner vorhanden hatte.
Also es sind einfach alles keine nennenswerte Vorschritte.
Diese Offensive wurde jetzt in den letzten Monaten von der Ukraine weitgehend erstickt.
Es gibt keine Fortschritte mehr und teilweise gewinnt die Ukraine sogar Boden
zurück. Und wir sehen jetzt, dass
die Angriffe auf Russland wiederum mit Langstreckenwaffen enorm zunehmen.
Das heißt, ich meine, wir haben in der letzten Sendung, glaube ich,
auch schon über dieses Jahr so gemutmaßt mit, dieses Jahr rechnen wir damit,
dass sich die Dinge ändern.
Wir waren, glaube ich, nicht sehr viel konkreter, aber wir haben gesagt, es ist was im Busch.
Das ist so, wie bisher, nicht weitergehen kann.
Und man muss auch nochmal das Ganze vor dem Hintergrund sehen,
dass seit Anfang 2025, seit Trump,
An der Macht ist, die USA ihre Unterstützung, ihre materielle Unterstützung
für die Ukraine komplett gekappt haben.
Das heißt, das Einzige, was jetzt die Ukrainer noch bekommen,
ist das, was die Europäer bei den Amerikanern einkaufen für die Ukraine,
plus das, was aus anderen Teilen der Welt dann geliefert wird.
Und das Information-Sharing natürlich, das findet nach wie vor statt.
Genau, also die Unterstützung mit Aufklärungs- und Kommunikationsmitteln,
die ist nicht zu unterschätzen.
Starlink vor allem so hat sich bewährt und da hatten wir auch schon,
dass die Russen ja abgeschnitten wurden.
Und das...
Machen muss, das war keine Maßnahme der US-Regierung.
Sondern das ist, wie man jetzt auch hört, im Wesentlichen ein,
Erfolg dieses neuen Chefs des russischen Intergeheimdienstes Fedorov.
Ukrainischen.
Des ukrainischen. Budanov, der ja auch legendär war, der ist ja in politische
Feld gewechselt und Fedorov ist ähm,
Jetzt der Nachfolger gewesen und das ist ja der Typ, der die Ukraine,
diese Digitalisierung der Ukraine auch so nach vorne gebracht hat.
Also dieses DIA zum Beispiel, diese App, mit der alle Ukrainer quasi ihr Relationship
zum Staat organisieren.
Also Anfragen steuern, blablabla, alles. Das war sein Projekt und der ist halt
sehr jung und sehr dynamisch.
Und der ist jetzt auch derjenige, der das ukrainische Militär komplett auf diesen
Drohnenkrieg umgestellt hat.
Und der hatte wohl offenbar auch einen ganz guten Draht zu Elon Musk und hat
darüber über einen kurzen Dienstweg das wohl erreicht.
Wenn man den Berichten glauben mag. Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall ist die Situation
jetzt so, dass die Ukraine Russland teilweise schon mit mehr Material,
also mit mehr Raketen pro Tag angreift als umgekehrt.
Das ist schon mal bemerkenswert, wobei nicht mit derselben Art von Raketen,
sondern, werden wir auch gleich noch darüber berichten, das ist im Wesentlichen
ein modernes Drohnenmaterial, was die Ukraine selber entwickelt hat.
Während Russland nach wie vor auch mit Drohnen, aber vor allem eben immer noch
mit ballistischen Raketen und Long Range Missiles angreift.
Trotzdem rein quantitativ dreht sich da das Blatt auch und was halt vor allem
der große Erfolg der letzten Wochen,
ein, zwei Monate ist, das findet ja nicht alles von jetzt auf sofort statt,
sondern das sind Prozesse, die werden eingeleitet und irgendwann entfallen.
Halten die sich, aber diese Todeszone, diese Greyzone.
Die wir so bisher, was weiß ich, am Anfang waren das so 5 bis 10 Kilometer,
dann ist es jetzt schon vor ein paar Monaten haben wir schon davon gesprochen,
dass sie sich so auf 50 Kilometer teilweise auch ausdehnt.
Also das ist sozusagen der Streifen, wo dieser Frontverlauf nicht so klar definierbar
ist und wo die Russen auch überhaupt erstmal durchkommen müssen,
um überhaupt in irgendeiner Form die Front voranzutreiben.
Weil das einfach so ein Gebiet ist und gut 70% der Leute, die also in diese
Zone treten, erreichen diese Front nie.
Weil die einfach schon vorher von dieser Totalüberwachung von Drohnen abgefangen werden.
Diese Zone ist offensichtlich jetzt nochmal größer geworden.
Zumindest ist der Ukraine jetzt gelungen, im Bereich bis zu 100 Kilometern.
Durch die Verminderung der Luftabwehr, durch neue Drohnentechnologie,
man weiß es nicht so richtig, was alles zu diesem Durchbruch geführt hat,
aber man sieht jetzt täglich Bilder von Drohnen, die Free Roaming sind,
in diesem besetzten Streifen zwischen Mariupol und der Krim.
Und das ist natürlich ein absoluter Gamechanger hier an dieser Stelle,
weil das ist die Versorgungsstraße der Krim.
Und was nicht über diese Straße kommt, das erreicht diese Krim nicht,
weil halt die Kerzbrücke, die ja eigentlich mal für diese Versorgung gedacht
war, wurde von der Ukraine extrem angegriffen. Züge kommen dann nicht durch.
Es gibt noch Truckverkehr, aber auch nur eingeschränkt, weil die Belastbarkeit
der Brücke nicht so groß ist.
Die Fähren, die fuhren, sind alle zerstört worden.
Und das ist jetzt die Lifeline. Und um halt die Krim überhaupt am Leben zu erhalten.
Nicht nur die Krim, sondern auch die Saperischer Front.
Na klar, genau. Also im Prinzip der gesamte Streifen bis nach Resson wird darüber versorgt. Und ja, es,
Werden einfach täglich dort Trucks angegriffen, Tankfahrzeuge angegriffen,
Militärequipment und eben so Sprittransporter.
Die Straße wandelt sich langsam auch zu so einer neuen Todeszone und das ist
definitiv eine Änderung.
Das ist auch nicht nur der Bereich, sondern auch im Donetsk gibt es einfach
in einem vermehrten Maße Angriffe auf die Logistik und das ist natürlich für
die Russen nochmal ein extra Problem, weil sie jetzt noch weiter zurück gehen müssen.
Also wir hatten das schon mal, als es mit diesen ersten Heimars-Angriffen losging,
das hat die Russen ja auch etwas unvorbereitet getroffen, dann haben sie so
nach ein, zwei Monaten reagiert und alles mehr ins Hinterland verlegt.
Jetzt sieht es ganz so aus, als ob sie noch sehr viel mehr ins Hinterland bis
nach Russland selbst zurück sich ziehen müssten, um in irgendeiner Form sicher
zu sein vor diesen Angriffen.
Also um diesen Überblick jetzt erstmal so abzurunden, das ist das,
was im Wesentlichen im Kriegsgeschehen passiert ist.
Im Detail ist natürlich noch eine ganze Menge mehr passiert.
Ja, vielleicht noch eine interessante Information, die mir gerade eingefallen ist.
Ich meine, es finden nach wie vor, spielt Artillerie auch noch eine große Rolle in dem Krieg.
Also auch trotz der Drohnen ist der Artilleriekrieg auch in vollem Gange.
Also insbesondere jetzt mit Kanonenartillerie.
Und da gab es jetzt im letzten Monat eine interessante Meldung von Rheinmetall,
die sagten, dass sie jetzt die
Produktion von 155 Millimeter Munition in Deutschland oder Deutschland,
In Rheinmetall, wahrscheinlich auch mit dem einen oder anderen außerdeutschen
Stützpunkt, auf 1,1 Millionen pro Jahr gesteigert haben.
Also knapp verfünffacht haben gegenüber dem Vorjahr und irgendwie nochmal über
zwei Millionen kleinere Kalibergranaten produzieren.
Und bei den 155 Millimetern produziert Rheinmetall jetzt mehr Munition als die
gesamte US-Rüstungsindustrie zusammen.
Also offenbar, wenn man sich hier entschließt, dann die Produktion auszuweiten,
dann war ja nicht so ganz klar, wie dynamisch sind wir denn hier so in Europa jetzt mit dem Aufwuchs.
Und zumindest, ich sag mal, an dieser Stelle muss man sagen, hm, okay.
Und sie planen eben auch weiteren Ausbau, ja.
Genau, aber ich wollte jetzt erstmal nur das allgemeine Kriegsgeschehen einen Überblick liefern.
Wir kommen ja gleich noch zu dieser Militärtechnik und den ganzen anderen Details. Ja.
Ja, womit fangen wir an? Also diese Angriffe der Ukraine auf Russland waren
das Thema der letzten zwei Monate und sind eigentlich auch das Thema nach wie
vor in der täglichen Kriegsberichterstattung,
weil einfach so viele davon stattfinden und auch sehr viele, sehr viel Erfolg haben.
Es ist nämlich so ganz klar, wie es der Ukraine eigentlich gelungen ist,
aber es scheint ihnen gelungen zu sein, Wege zu finden,
wie sie gezielt und mit sehr hoher Schlagkraft die Luftverteidigungssysteme der Russen ausknocken.
Also Schätzungen gehen da so in den Bereich, dass sie so pro Tag ein oder zwei
Flugabwehrsysteme ausschalten, vielleicht sind es auch noch ein paar mehr.
Das ist auf jeden Fall schon eine beträchtliche Zahl.
Mit Luftabwehr meinen wir halt so Systeme wie die Panziersysteme,
die so für Kurzstrecken sind,
Thor-Systeme, dann S-300, S-400, also alles was in irgendeiner Form den Himmel
beobachtet und versucht Angriffe abzuwehren.
Und diese Systeme werden einfach niedergemäht derzeit.
Nur ein bisschen Nitpicking, Luftverteidigung oder Flugabwehr.
Du hast Luftabwehr gesagt, aber so Luft braucht man nicht abzuwehren.
Ja, ja, okay. Böse Luft.
Genau, also Luftverteidigung. Also diese Systeme, dann natürlich,
da gehören dann die Launcher dazu, da gehören Radarsysteme dazu,
teilweise eben auch die Kommandozentralen.
Das sind ja meistens so Systeme, die aus mehreren Komponenten bestehen.
Wie auch immer, es werden auf jeden Fall mindestens pro Tag eine,
manchmal auch zwei weggehauen.
Und das ist viel, weil diese Systeme, die kriegt man nicht mal so eben nachproduziert.
Und vor allem mit jeder Einzelnen, die in irgendeiner Form zerstört wurde,
die ist ja für einen bestimmten Bereich tätig, wird wieder ein neuer Kanal eröffnet,
durch den man was durchschicken kann, ohne in irgendeiner Form eine Antwort zu erwarten.
Ja, also ich hatte mir die Zahlen auch für März, April und Mai tatsächlich mal rausgesucht.
Und das waren so zwischen, in der Summe mindestens je nach Monat,
30 bis 40 Systeme pro Monat, die nachweislich zerstört wurden.
Also wo die Ukraine dann auch entsprechendes Filmmaterial veröffentlicht hat.
Das heißt, wie du gesagt hast, die Untergrenze liegt bei 30 bis 40 pro Monat im Moment.
Also ja, so sagt es, ein bis zwei Systeme.
Pro Tag. Und ja, die Folgen können wir dann eben auch sehen,
wie du schon erwähnt hast, dass jetzt mittlerweile die Ukrainer dann Drohnen
weit im Hinterland spazieren fliegen.
Genau, also nicht nur Drohnen, sondern es kommen teilweise auch noch Stormshadows,
die gibt es also auch noch.
Die sieht man jetzt nicht mehr so oft, aber die werden jetzt gezielt dafür eingesetzt,
wenn es darum geht, wirklich komplette Fabrikkomplexe auszuhuten.
Im März ging das stark los in Brianz,
so ein Mikroelektronikwerk, was halt von dem berichtet wurde,
es sei unter anderem eben für die Herstellung von Bauteilen für diese Iskander-Raketen
zuständig, aber es gab auch Chemiewerke, alle aller Art.
Also alles, was in irgendeiner Form auch Zulieferer für diesen militärischen Komplex der Russen ist,
ist da ins Fadenkreuz der Ukraine geraten und wenn man halt die Möglichkeit
hat, da wirklich mit Stormshadow einzuschlagen, also Bryansk ist ja relativ nah dran an der Ukraine,
dann wurde das eben getan und die Schäden waren also teilweise wirklich verheerend.
Also wenn man da die Bilder sich angeschaut hat, dann war klar,
dass da so relativ wenig von übrig geblieben ist von diesen Werken.
Also da sind so im Schnitt ein bis zwei Rüstungsfabriken pro Woche.
Also zwischen fünf und zehn pro Monat in den letzten Monaten,
nur um mal die Größenordnungen auch noch zu erwähnen. erwähnen, ja.
Weil so viele hat auch hat auch Russland nicht davon und man macht sich ja auch mal nicht klar.
Es gibt also so bestimmte Dinge, die hergestellt werden, sind dann einfach auch
teilweise eine kritische Ressource, um Sprengstoff zu erzeugen oder um Radarsysteme
zu bauen, braucht man einfach bestimmte Elektronik und wenn dann einfach,
Wenn das nicht mehr erzeugt werden kann, dann kann es auch gar nicht mehr bauen.
Das ist einfache Geschichte.
Es ist klar, auch in der Ukraine geht immer mal wieder was in Flammen auf.
Darüber wird natürlich nicht so viel berichtet, weil die Ukrainer halten natürlich
dann deutlich dichter, als es den Russen regelmäßig gelingt.
Aber naja, wir sehen ja auch an der Produktionsfähigkeit der Ukraine,
dass die Russen da so viel Erfolg nicht mit haben.
Deswegen sieht es hier eben auch zunehmend schlecht aus für Russland.
Aber nichts wurde so stark getroffen wie die Ölinfrastruktur.
Das ist ja im Prinzip jetzt auch keine neue Geschichte hier.
Aber es ging halt jetzt in den letzten Monaten, ja im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes
Schlag um Schlag weiter.
Die Ziele waren halt eigentlich alles, also Lager, Ölhäfen.
Pipelines, Pumpstationen, alles was in irgendeiner Form Teil dieses Produktions-
und Distributionssystems der Russen war in Bezug auf die Ölinfrastruktur war Opfer.
Und die Opfer waren groß, die dort fielen.
Also die Ölhäfen in Primorsk und in Ustluga, das sind die beiden großen Ölverschiffungshäfen
an der Ostsee, die wurden, ich weiß nicht genau, wie man es sagen soll, aber schwer getroffen.
Teilweise waren die wochenlang nicht im Betrieb was jetzt überhaupt derzeit
davor noch im Betrieb ist, kann ich nur drüber spekulieren wahrscheinlich nicht sehr viel,
Und die Brände hat man von Finnland aus gesehen, also da musste man noch nicht
mal auf Smartphones von Einwohnern vertrauen.
Das war alles über die Grenze zu sehen.
Es gab auch nicht nur einen Angriff, sondern es gab alle drei Tage dann wieder
den nächsten Angriff. Also immer wenn dann die Rauchsäulen weg waren und man
mal sehen konnte, was noch überlebt hat, dann kam schon die nächste Welle.
Also über zwei Wochen wurden diese Ölhäfen angegriffen, das brannte wochenlang
und ja, die Schätzung, wie viel Prozent jetzt dieser Exportfähigkeit wirklich genommen wurde,
da habe ich so viele verschiedene Zahlen gehört, dass ich mich auf überhaupt
gar nichts einigen möchte, aber dass das erheblich.
Die Exportfähigkeit Russlands eingeschränkt hat, das ist vollkommen unbenommen.
Das sieht man einfach daran, dass einfach die Exportzahlen selber runtergegangen
sind. Also Russland nimmt einfach kein Geld mehr damit ein.
Also im Peak kann man davon ausgehen,
man kann dann sehen,
wie viele Schiffe dort anlegen und dann Öl aufnehmen Und für die Woche oder
so waren die gesamten Häfen erst mal offline für eine Woche mindestens.
Und das entspricht dann etwa 40 Prozent der Exportkapazität.
Aber mittlerweile wird schon wieder Öl verladen dort.
Also es ist nicht so, dass sie das jetzt komplett ausgenockt hätten,
aber die Schäden sind massiv und ja, es ist schwer immer abzuschätzen auch, weil...
Und bisher war es immer so, im Jahresmittel waren dann diese kinetischen Sanktionen
der Ukraine zwar auch wirksam,
aber in der Summe dann eher im einstelligen Prozentbereich.
Ja, weil die Russen schon auch sehr gut sind darin, Dinge wieder instand zu
setzen oder improvisiert instand zu setzen.
Aber inzwischen ist der Eindruck,
dass man rechnet damit,
dass es tatsächlich übers Jahr hinweg zwischen 10 und 20 Prozent sein könnten,
um die Ölexporte zurückgegangen sind aufgrund dieser kinetischen Sanktionen.
Auf der anderen Seite hat dann die USA natürlich wieder Sanktionen ausgesetzt
und so und der Preis ist höher,
aber unterm Strich, ja ohne diese kinetischen Sanktionen der Ukraine stünde
Russland deutlich besser da.
Ja und es trifft sich halt zur Unzeit, weil natürlich durch den Iran-Krieg ist
der Ölpreis natürlich nach oben gegangen, das wäre eine super Gelegenheit gewesen
hier in irgendeiner Form mal wieder Cash zu machen,
aber zumal ja auch noch die USA
dann noch ein paar Sanktionen auf Russland gelockert hat, mal so nebenbei,
aber dazu kam es nicht, also die Einnahmen sinken und letztes Jahr haben auch
alle großen Ölfirmen miese gemacht in Russland und es wird nicht besser werden.
Genau so hat es die Ölhäfen getroffen im Schwarzen Meer.
Dort gibt es halt vor allem die beiden großen Häfen in Novorossisk und in Tuapse.
Novorossisk ist ja auch dieser Militärhafen, wo auch noch große Schiffe liegen
und dort auch schon wieder angegriffen wurden.
Ja, die wurden dann nebenbei noch mitgenommen, glaube ich.
Ja, es waren auch separate Angriffe vorher schon, aber jetzt kamen halt in zunehmendem
Maße auch nochmal Angriffe auf die Tanklager dort.
Besonders hart getroffen hat es halt Tuapse, was halt so ein riesiger Hafen ist,
im Sinne von, dass sie dort sehr viel Öl lagern, also die halbe Stadt besteht
da im Wesentlichen aus so Öltanks und davon wurden, glaube ich,
gut 80 Prozent zerstört.
Das war so krass. Das gilt auch, glaube ich, für Primors, dass es also dort
nicht nur tagelang gebrannt hat, sondern halt auch tagelang Öl geregnet hat.
Also super krasse Bilder.
Das ist ziemlich fies.
Also es ist natürlich weder gut für die Leute dort noch für die Umwelt an sich.
Aber das ist halt nochmal so eine Auswirkung davon. Die Ukraine hat diese Tanklager
natürlich angegriffen, um diesen Floh zu unterbrechen, weil in dem Moment,
wo es dort keine Tanklager gibt, kann man halt nichts hinpumpen und dann kann
man halt auch nichts in Schiffe pumpen.
Also so wie das dort aussieht, glaube ich nicht, dass noch sehr viel Öl exportiert
wird durch das Schwarze Meer.
Ich schätze mal, das dürfte weitgehend zum Erliegen gekommen sein.
Auch der Gasexporthafen, dessen Name mir gerade entfallen ist, wurde angegriffen.
Also generell sieht es da nicht gut aus.
Die Russen haben natürlich noch ein paar Exporthäfen im fernen Osten.
Aber da gehen die Pipelines nicht alle hin.
Also das sind nur wenige Prozent des Gesamtexports.
Das meiste läuft einfach über die Ostsee und über das Schwarze Meer,
beziehungsweise jetzt nicht mehr gefördert. Die Förderstellen wurden auch angegriffen,
vor allem im Kaspischen Meer.
Dort gab es Angriffe auf Ölbohrplattformen, Angriffe auf Häfen, auf Schiffe.
Also auch dort zahlreiche Schläge und es ist bemerkenswert, dass die Ukraine
überhaupt in der Lage ist, im Kaspischen Meer auch anzugreifen,
weil es ja nun auch relativ weit weg ist.
Und dann ging es natürlich auch noch weiter mit Angriffen auf die zahlreichen
Ölraffinerien, von denen Russland ja eine ganze Menge hat.
Da gibt es ja diese schöne Oil Refinery Bingo, so eine Karte,
die immer rausgezogen wird, wenn mal wieder ein neuer Angriff gelaufen ist und alle...
Ölraffinerien, die in irgendeiner Form in der Reichweite der Ukraine sind,
also bis zu 1500 oder bis zu 2000 Kilometer, glaube ich, gegen die Angriffe
schon, haben also mehrfach schon Besuch bekommen.
Und auch die größten Raffinerien werden jetzt regelmäßig angegriffen und die
Intensität dieser Schläge scheint auch zuzunehmen.
Also während es mal eine Drohne gab, die mal irgendetwas angegriffen hat,
sind es jetzt immer gleich ganze Baragen von Drohnen, die durchkommen und es
scheint alles nur noch schlimmer zu werden.
Ja, also mengenmäßig so jeden Monat zwischen acht und zwölf Raffinerieangriffe,
also zwei bis drei pro Woche.
Und teilweise, auch in kurzen Abständen, teilweise waren drei Raffinerien gleichzeitig
in Branden in Russland, zum Beispiel am 20.
April. so und eine dieser Raffinerien war ja dann auch nahe Moskau,
die getroffen wurde, das ist vielleicht noch bemerkenswert,
so dass auch die Leute in Moskau dann sehen konnten dass da in der Nähe eine
Raffinerie brennt so das,
macht sich.
Nicht so gut in der Propaganda, auf jeden Fall, weil das kann man nicht so richtig stillschweigen,
Dann Pumpstationen, auch nicht ganz unwichtig, diese Pipelines sind ja essentiell
für diese gesamte Ölproduktion Russlands und auch hier wurden viele Ölpumpstationen
direkt angegriffen und diese Pumpstationen fließt halt nichts durch die Pipelines
und wenn nichts durch die Pipelines fließt,
dann kann man halt auch nichts exportieren und auch in zunehmendem Maße auch
nicht fördern, Weil es ist ja all diese ganze Unterbrechung des permanenten Exports.
Das bedeutet ja auch, dass wenn es keine Weiterleitung gibt,
können auch diese Ölquellen nicht mehr liefern.
Und Russland läuft halt Gefahr, dass wenn sie nicht mehr das Öl,
was sie pumpen, also was sie aus der Erde pumpen, wenn sie das nicht wegtransportiert
bekommen, dann müssen sie halt die Pumpen abschalten.
Aber wenn sie die Pumpen abschalten in Sibirien, dann frieren ihnen die Pumpen ein.
Und dann war es das erstmal mit der Pumpe. Die kann man nicht einfach an- und ausschalten.
Ich habe relativ wenig darüber gelesen, ob das jetzt auch schon stattgefunden
hat in irgendeiner Form.
Das kann natürlich sein, aber drohen tut es auf jeden Fall.
Ja, was halt wohl passiert, ich hätte mir nochmal angeguckt,
dass sogar die Ölquellen selbst und teilweise auch die Leitungen,
dass sich dort Wachspropfen im Wesentlichen bilden.
Und dadurch, ja, es fließt dann nicht mehr, weil es wird dann halt, ja, es ist dann solide.
Und du musst dann im Prinzip die neu aufbohren,
die Quellen dann, wenn das einmal
passiert ist und wie viel das passiert tatsächlich ist, ist die Frage.
Ich traue den Russen dann durchaus zu, alle möglichen krassen Szenarien dann
noch zu fahren oder was du machen kannst.
Du kannst halt dann improvisierte Tanks relativ schnell konstruieren,
wo du dann das hindammst Oder im Zweifelsfall nehmen sie irgendeinen Tal oder
so und pumpen dann erstmal das Öl einfach irgendwo in die Landschaft,
um zu vermeiden, dass die Leitungen einfrieren, würde ich denen eigentlich voll zutrauen.
Ich habe jetzt keine Hinweise darauf, dass das so ist, außer dass das wahrscheinlich
ist und dass auch der Iran zum Beispiel...
Ganz gut in der Lage ist, seine Ölproduktion rauf und runter zu fahren.
Aber in Sibirien ist es nochmal eine andere Kiste, als im Iran,
wenn das Öl nahe der Oberfläche liegt.
Das ist ein kleineres Problem als in Sibirien.
Aber wird man sehen, auf jeden Fall mit diesen,
die Pumpstationen, die betroffen waren, Dann waren halt unter anderem die Druschwa-Pipeline,
die halt Westeuropa versorgt hat oder auch versorgt.
Aber dann vielleicht das Transneft-Hauptpipeline-System, was dann teilweise
was aus Sibirien kommt, dann in Richtung Osten oder Westen verteilen kann.
Und dann wurden speziell eben auch die Exportrouten, einmal die nach Novorossisk gehen,
angegriffen in den Süden und auch noch Direktsysteme, die nach Belarus pumpen.
Und ja, teilweise eine dieser Pumpstationen, auch eine der großen,
die haben halt auch noch Pufferspeicher, weil sie dann mal zwischenzeitlich
vielleicht mal anhalten müssen.
Um den Fluss über weite Strecken zu entkoppeln.
Und diese Pufferspeicher wurden halt auch komplett zerstört,
was es halt zwar nicht unmöglich macht, Öl zu pumpen, aber eben schwieriger
macht, das ganze System zu managen.
Also je mehr da kaputt geht, umso mehr Ausfälle hast du, umso mehr Probleme
hast du und umso weniger kannst du wahrscheinlich insgesamt pumpen.
Es scheint auf jeden Fall signifikante Auswirkungen zu haben und zu verhindern,
dass Russland mehr exportiert und zugeführt hat,
dass der Export zurückgeht.
Ja, dann wie schon eingangs erwähnt, die Angriffe auf die Transportrouten,
auf die ganze Logistik im Hinterland der Front.
Und diese totale Überwachung, also es ist crazy, wenn man sich diese Videos anschaut, weil, okay.
Dass da mal eine Drohne irgendwo hinfliegt, ja, aber die Drohnen,
die die Ukrainer hier zeigen, also die Videos, die sie zeigen von diesen Drohnen,
die von diesen Drohnen gemacht werden, das ist schon mehr so ein Patrouillen der Stadt,
beziehungsweise auch dieser Verbindungsstraße zwischen den großen Städten.
Also sowohl über den großen Städten wie Mariupol fliegen die Drohnen einfach
so übers offene Land und man sieht richtig, wie die Russen keinerlei Vorkehrungen
getroffen haben für diesen Fall, sich dort sehr sicher gefühlt haben,
weil auf der ukrainischen Seite hinter der Front, nicht wahr.
Da sind halt alle Straßen mit Netzen abgedeckt, um dort die Transporte in irgendeiner
Form vor anfliegenden FPV-Drohnen zu sichern.
Hier ist halt nichts dergleichen und da ist so ganz normaler Verkehr und eben sehr viele LKWs,
die dort unterwegs sind und die Drohnen suchen die sich raus und rein und mit
jedem Video sieht man immer mehr Wracks liegen links und rechts von dieser Straße.
Also es ist wirklich eine totale Killzone und offensichtlich sind die Russen
hier komplett auf dem linken Fuß erwischt worden, weil sie da jetzt erstmal
auch offensichtlich keinerlei Abwehr haben.
Also sie haben zwar die Flugabwehr, aber haben wir ja schon gesagt,
die ist halt in zunehmendem Maße dezimiert, steht vielleicht wenn überhaupt woanders,
da werden dann Korridore frei und ja, jetzt haben sie das Problem,
dass ihnen also die Logistik zerbomb wird. und.
Krieg ist im Wesentlichen Logistik. Und wenn die Logistik nicht funktioniert,
dann können halt die Fronten nicht versorgt werden.
Nicht mit Waffen, nicht mit Nahrung, nicht mit Material, mit Kleidung, mit was auch immer.
Ja, und die Patrouillendichte war teilweise so hoch, dass sich die ukrainischen
Drohnen in der Luft dort begegnet sind.
Also konntest du dann von einer Drohne sehen, wie irgendwie eine andere ukrainische
Drohne entgegenkam aus der anderen Richtung und ja, zu den Wracks.
Was noch interessant ist, war so ungefähr halbe, halbe Militärfahrzeuge und
die andere Hälfte zivile Trucks.
Wobei man dann merken muss, dass auf beiden Seiten das Militär größere Mengen
einfach an zivilen Fahrzeugen benutzt, die dann als solche nicht markiert sind.
Insofern, das ist natürlich ein Problem, weil dadurch eben auch zivile Transporte
oder Zivilisten natürlich gefährdet werden.
Aber das ist dann halt so. Ich habe dann auch ein Video gesehen von einem Russen,
der da in den letzten Tagen lang gefahren ist mit seinem PKW bei Nacht.
Und dann nur so meinte, ja, und der Er sei ja gewarnt worden irgendwie mehrfach an den Kontroll,
am Checkpoint, dass es irgendwie gefährlich sei und er doch da nicht irgendwie
lieber langfahren sollte.
Er scheint da zwar sicher mit seinem PKW durchgekommen zu sein,
aber meinte dann, es sei überhaupt kein Verkehr auf der ganzen Strecke.
Er meint, er sei kaum Fahrzeuge unterwegs und es sei doch ein bisschen irgendwie
spooky, gerade dort langzufahren.
Ja, krass.
Und eine Sache noch, ein interessantes Bild gesehen, ich weiß nicht,
ob das gesehen ist, und zwar ein LKW mit einem Anti-KI-Tarnmuster.
Ja dann im Prinzip haben sie so ein Zebra-Muster,
extrem kontrastreich mit Linien, ungefähr 5 cm breiten weißen Linien,
die so ja, sich über den gesamten LKW ziehen.
Unklar, ob,
Ob das funktioniert, weiß ich nicht, aber das ist so eine der Dinge,
mit denen die Russen gerade experimentieren in dem Zusammenhang,
weil das ein echtes Problem zu sein scheint mit der KI,
also Endanflug mit KI.
Ja, wobei ich nicht unbedingt so den Eindruck hatte, dass das jetzt komplett
autonom agierende Drohnen sind, sondern vielmehr, dass die Ukraine in irgendeiner
Form einen Weg gefunden hat, dort die Kommunikation sicherzustellen.
Das kann also Starlink sein, dass diese Drohnen mit Starlink Terminals ausgestattet
sind und dass die halt einfach da jetzt Free Roaming sind und die Russen keine
entsprechenden Electronic Warfare Systeme haben,
um Starlink auszuschalten und wenn dem so ist, dann gute Nacht.
Also das ist, man kann jetzt sagen so, ja okay gut, dann hauen sie da halt ein
bisschen die Logistik weg, was kann das schon groß bringen.
Wir reden aber jetzt hier nicht über irgendeine Region, sondern wir reden wirklich
über diese Lifeline der Krim und Kherson und Saporizhia hast du ja auch schon
richtig gesagt, also im Prinzip dieser gesamte südliche besetzte Teil.
Weil sollte es den Russen nicht gelingen, ihre Logistik dort aufrecht zu erhalten
und die Fronten zu verstärken oder zumindest überhaupt erstmal so stark zu halten, wie sie gerade sind.
Dann erhöht das natürlich die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass die Ukrainer mit Gegenangriffen hier auch Erfolg haben.
Tatsächlich gibt es einen solchen Gegenangriff bereits zu sehen und zwar ist
ja diese Stelle da bei Inahoda und Saporizhia,
also der großen Stadt Saporizhia recht nah gekommen und da finden Kämpfe statt.
Also wenn solche Vorstöße jetzt noch wahrscheinlicher werden,
dann kann man schon langsam ein bisschen optimistischer werden,
dass es den Ukrainern vielleicht auch wirklich gelingt, diesen Frontverlauf
noch weiter nach hinten zu drücken.
Das wäre speziell an diesem Punkt in Saporizhia ganz wichtig,
aber natürlich auch generell überall.
Ob das so kommen wird, würde ich sagen, ist noch offen.
Offensive Maßnahmen bedeutet halt auch immer zusätzliche Gefährdung für das
eigene Personal und davon hat ja die Ukraine nicht so viel und sie haben jetzt
durch diese totale Automatisierung ihrer Logistik,
wir reden auch gleich nochmal über die Bodendrohnen,
Und klar, das Ziel, hier die Leute eben auch wirklich aus dem eigentlichen Gefahrenraum
rauszuhalten und sozusagen die Russen automatisiert zu bekämpfen,
das funktioniert natürlich bei einer Offensive nur sehr begrenzt.
In der Summe sagen wir,
dass in den letzten Monaten netto die Ukrainer mehr Territorium zurückerobert
haben oder befreit haben,
als die Russen erobert haben.
Aber beide Seiten haben territoriale Gewinne zu verzeichnen an verschiedenen Stellen der Front.
Aber die Ukraine jetzt in der Summe hat ein Parkverdrahtkilometer mehr zurückgewonnen als Russland.
Aber wenn es in dem Tempo weitergeht, braucht die Ukraine auch 100 Jahre,
um wieder alles zurückzuerobern,
so wie die Russen irgendwie 100 Jahre brauchen würden, um irgendwie die Ukraine zu erobern.
Das ist klar, aber es zeigt zumindest,
die Russen können gestoppt werden und werden gerade gestoppt und ich wäre jetzt nicht überrascht,
wenn wir jetzt hören werden, dass auch die Vorstöße dort, wo die Russen gerade
am kräftigsten drücken, auch aufgehalten werden können.
Also dass sozusagen der vollständige Vormarsch der Russen gestoppt werden kann, egal wo man hinschaut.
Lassen wir mal noch weiter schauen, wie die Ukraine das macht.
Neben den gezielten Angriffen auf diese Logistikrouten gibt es auch wieder vermehrt
Angriffe auf Flughäfen und andere Militärbasen.
Wir erinnern uns noch an diese Aktion Spiderweb mit den Trucks,
wo sie dann die Drohnen direkt an die Militärgelände gefahren haben und einen
Großteil der strategischen Nuklearflugzeuge,
also der strategischen, wie hieß es so schön, der strategischen Flotte der Russen zerstört haben.
Es gibt natürlich auch noch viele andere nette Ziele auf anderen Militärbasen
und irgendwie gelingt es jetzt auch den Ukrainern offenbar, Drohnen an diese
Flughäfen ranzubringen.
Da sind verschiedene Maßnahmen genannt worden, also das Drohnen Drohnen transportieren.
Das ist sozusagen eine Methode, dass sie sozusagen Long-Range-Drohnen nehmen,
um Short-Range-Drohnen irgendwo hinzubekommen, die dann erstmal in der Nähe
von so einer Militärbasis abgesetzt werden.
Und wenn dann Flugzeuge landen, dann werden die angegriffen oder was weiß ich,
vielleicht auch kurz bevor sie starten.
Ich habe da verschiedene Sachen gehört, auch dass so ein Transport durch Ballons,
dass man also auch Ballons startet und weil wohl die Luftströmung in der Regel
nach Osten gehen mehrheitlich,
ist das etwas, was die Ukraine ganz gut machen kann.
Da frage ich mich halt nur, wie gezielt dann sowas sein kann.
Aber klar, durch so einen Ballon kann man natürlich Nennswertstrecke in irgendeiner
Form zurücklegen, ohne jetzt große Energie zu verbrauchen.
Und dann kann sich halt so eine Drohne abkoppeln und sehr viel weiter im Hinterland noch angreifen.
Das mag durchaus etwas sein, was man noch häufiger sieht. Auf jeden Fall sind
sehr viele Militärflugzeuge zerstört worden in den letzten Wochen.
Große Transportflugzeuge, Bomber, alles mögliche,
die wohl auf Flughäfen standen und an Militärbasen standen, wo sich die Russen
wohl sicher waren, dass sie da erstmal nichts auf der Aume kriegen.
Scheint auch nicht so gut zu funktionieren.
Kurzer Blick dann noch auf den Seekrieg, wo ja eigentlich die Ukraine schon
jetzt seit zwei Jahren die Oberhand hat.
Dort gibt es jetzt vor allem neue Angriffe auf sanktionierte Tanker.
Also die Militärschiffe sind da eh kaum noch unterwegs, aber die Tanker sind
natürlich noch unterwegs.
Da sind welche angegriffen worden, auch vor der Kerchbrücke, also in dieser Region.
Also mit anderen Worten, die Ukraine agiert auch mit ihren Drohnensystemen nach
wie vor direkt vor russischen Gewässern.
Angriffe auf das U-Boot hatten wir hier glaube ich schon mal besprochen mit
dieser mutmaßlichen Unterwasserdrohne. vollkommen unklar, was sie dort alles einsetzen.
Marine-Drohnen werden auf jeden Fall auch so als Flugzeugträger benutzt,
dass man also damit auch die Drohnen immer irgendwo hinbringt und dann vom Ufer
aus oder nahe des Ufers aus diese Flugplätze angreift.
All das findet statt.
Aber auch die Franzosen sind jetzt ganz gut dabei und haben schon verschiedene
Tankerhops genommen, die eben gegen die Sanktionen verstoßen und die wurden
dann auf offener See aufgebracht.
Hat auch so eine Folge, dass russische LNG-Tanker wohl.
Das Mittelmeer meiden, weil ihnen dort zu leicht aufgelauert wird.
Wobei das wohl damit zu tun hatte, dass die Ukraine in Libyen Truppen stationiert hat,
die von dort aus dann Angriffe mit eben Wasserdrohnen durchgeführt haben auf
vorbeifahrende russische Schiffe.
Genau, also ein LNG-Tanker wurde dort angegriffen, der ist dann auch so teilweise wegexplodiert.
Das ist ja nicht ganz so ein Problem wie jetzt einen Öltanker,
der, wenn der voll beladen ist, ein riesiges ökologisches Desaster auslösen würde.
Bei LNG, also schön ist das jetzt auch nicht, aber wenn dieses Flüssiggas,
wenn der Tank gesprengt wird sozusagen von dem Flüssiggas, dann löst sich das
halt einfach in Gas, in Luft auf sozusagen.
Bleibt natürlich noch dieser Tanker, ich weiß nicht, ob der mittlerweile weggeschleppt
werden konnte, der ist da auf jeden Fall rumgedümpelt im Mittelmeer,
das war natürlich jetzt kein schöner Anblick,
aber grundsätzlich hat wohl die Warnung gereicht und für Russland ist halt auch
das Mittelmeer an der Stelle in zunehmendem Maße ein No-Go.
Ja, die russische Luftfahrt an sich, also auch die zivile hat also auch deswegen enorme Probleme,
weil ihnen natürlich jetzt durch die mangelhafte Wartung und vielleicht auch
der Wendewartung stattfindet, dann eben nicht durch Originalteile,
sondern von was weiß ich für Quellen.
Also diese zivile Flotte hat in zunehmendem Maße das Problem,
dass also hier Pannen und auch Abstürze zunehmen und offensichtlich fehlen ihnen
jetzt auch gut ausgebildete Piloten, ist auch ein Mangel,
da werden wahrscheinlich viele auch im Militär gelandet sein.
Also das ist an der Stelle auch nochmal so eine weitere Auswirkung.
Insgesamt russische Verluste sind groß an der Front.
Also Bodentruppen werden laut der Ukraine in der Größenordnung von 30.000 bis
35.000 Mann pro Monat getötet oder schwer verwundet.
Und man spricht von Verlusten.
Ukraine hat auch angekündigt, dass sie diese Zahl gerne noch auf 50.000 erhöhen wollen.
Und damit hat aber auf jeden Fall dieser Kill-Faktor schon eine Quantität,
die halt die Nachmobilisierung,
die Nachrekrutierung, Mobilisierung ist nicht das richtige Wort,
die Nachrekrutierung von neuen Soldaten auf der russischen Seite überschreitet.
Also es werden sozusagen mehr Leute an der Front getötet pro Monat oder verwundet.
Als die Russen in der Lage sind, neu auf das Kriegsfeld zu schicken.
Und das hat halt einerseits damit zu tun, dass so viele getötet werden,
aber es hat auch damit was zu tun, dass die Russen in zunehmendem Maße Probleme
haben, überhaupt noch Rekrutierungen durchzuführen, weil sie können dieses Geld nicht mehr bezahlen.
Die Prämien sind gesunken, das wird dann also auch uninteressant,
beziehungsweise es gibt einfach auch zunehmendermaßen Leute,
die dann realisieren, dass das sozusagen das Geld ihnen nicht viel bringt,
wenn sie da nach 10 Minuten auf dem Schlachtfeld enden.
Ist ein bisschen unklar, wie Russland dieses Problem eigentlich lösen möchte.
Teilweise, es gab so einen Tag im März, wo irgendwie über 1700 gestorben sind an einem Tag.
Also das ist einfach crazy.
Und so eine Mobilmachung, die ja immer mal wieder diskutiert wird,
ist eigentlich für Putin derzeit glaube ich keine Option,
weil das hat ja schon bei dieser teilweise Mobilisierung vor ein paar Jahren
nicht so gut funktioniert, da ist ihnen das Volk schon weitgehend abhandengekommen
und es gab entsprechend Aufruhr, aber in der aktuellen Situation,
wo sie ja auch sehr viel Ärger schon dadurch erzeugt haben, dass sie irgendwie
Internet abschalten und sowas.
Da haben sie einfach, wenn er das macht, dann wird es einfach Proteste geben
und ich glaube nicht, dass wir das sehen werden, so eine Generalmobilmachung.
Dann kommen wir doch nochmal kurz auf die Technik. Haben wir ja schon erwähnt,
dass hier eine Menge passiert und es scheint eben auch neben anderen Maßnahmen,
scheint es so sagen wir mal der zentrale Schlüssel glaube ich für den aktuellen
Erfolg der Ukraine zu sein, dass es ihnen gelungen ist,
ihre Militärtechnik weitgehend unter eigener Regie weiterzuentwickeln und dabei
vor allem im Bereich der Drohnen super erfolgreich zu sein.
Also man kann davon ausgehen, dass so weit über 90% aller Kills,
die durchgeführt werden, werden durch Drohnen durchgeführt.
Du meintest ja vorhin, Artillerie ist auch noch wichtig, so als Abstandswaffe, gar keine Frage.
Aber Drohnen sind einfach viel effizienter und können halt auch sehr viel sicherer betrieben werden.
Und es ist halt wirklich dramatisch, wenn man sich diese Videos anschaut,
wie also einfach diese Russen da alleine irgendwo in der Wildnis der Ukraine
im flachen Land da unterwegs sind und Tag und Nacht von diesen Drohnen aufgespürt
werden und dann einfach aus nächster Nähe zur Explosion gebracht werden.
Das ist halt einfach die Realität dort auf dem Schlachtfeld.
Es gibt sehr viele Unternehmen in der Ukraine, die diese Drohnen in allen Formen
und Farben produzieren.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele es sind, aber wir reden mit Sicherheit von Hunderten.
Besonders erfolgreich scheint aber diese Firma Firepoint zu sein,
die derzeit so ein bisschen die Krone aufzuhaben scheint.
Wir hatten das ja auch schon mehrfach erwähnt, diese Firepoint 1 und Firepoint
2, also FP1, FP2 Drohnen, sieht man jetzt eigentlich täglich in diesen Videos im Einsatz.
Also man kann vor allem diese FP2 sehr gut am Bild daran erkennen,
weil die so eine markante grüne Einblendung haben.
Deswegen ist immer schnell klar, dass die daran beteiligt sind.
Und die scheinen eine große Resistenz gegen Electronic Warfare zu haben,
in zunehmendem Maße auch so ein AI-basiertes Targeting zu haben,
sodass also auf den letzten Metern, die dann noch ihre Objekte selber direkt anfliegen können,
selbst wenn da die Verbindung abgerissen ist.
Natürlich die Glasfaserdrohnen spielen auch eine große Rolle,
aber so für diese Long-Range und Mid-Range-Erfolge scheint also wirklich dieses
Unternehmen Firepoint die Lösung zu haben.
Und sie steigern auch in zunehmendem Maße eben die Reichweite und die Sprengkraft dieser Drohnen.
Und wie schon erwähnt, diese Storm Shadow, also die britischen Missiles,
beziehungsweise teilweise kommen sie auch aus Frankreich, wie hießen sie da
nochmal, Skype Missiles.
Werden eben, wie schon erwähnt, so für High Value Targets eingesetzt.
Also wenn man eben eine ganze Fabrik platt machen will und wirklich so mit großer
Sprengkraft unterwegs sein will, dann nimmt man das.
Dafür haben die Ukrainer ja eigentlich diese Flamingo, diese FP5 gebaut,
wo immer noch so ein bisschen unklar ist, wie erfolgreich die eigentlich ist.
Also es wird immer wieder gesagt, dass die zum Einsatz kommen,
aber die regnen jetzt nicht so vom Himmel, wie man das vielleicht sich erhofft hätte.
Die sind halt einfach groß und langsam und deswegen wahrscheinlich noch ein
gefundenes Fressen für die verbliebenen Luftabwehr, Luftflugabwehrsysteme,
Entschuldigung, Luftverteidigungssysteme, ich kriege das noch auf die Reihe.
Wird man sehen, ist glaube ich auch alles unter konstanter Verbesserung und
von daher ist da gar kein finales Urteil zu sprechen.
Ich glaube, ein Problem, wenn ich das gehört habe,
ist, die Flamingos benutzen halt, sagen, alte sowjetische Jets,
soweit ich das gehört habe.
Und deren Verfügbarkeit scheint nicht so ganz, sie müssen halt dann vorher noch
irgendwie überholt werden und so.
Und jetzt gehört, es gäbe irgendwie Probleme wohl mit in großer Zahl,
in ausreichend großer Zahl, die Triebwerke dort zu beschaffen und dass man da
irgendwie auch noch jetzt neuen Triebwerken guckt oder so.
Aber.
Ja mit Vorsicht zu genießen das Ganze.
Ja was auf jeden Fall auch noch eine große Rolle spielt,
nicht nur in der Ukraine sondern wie wir das vorhin auch schon besprochen haben,
jetzt auch gerade im Krieg mit dem Iran sind die Interceptor Drohnen da habe
ich eine Zahl gesehen, Mitte wie war das Mitte März,
März bis Mitte April, in diesem Zeitraum, also ungefähr so fünf, sechs Wochen,
wurden durch Interceptor Drohnen, also diese superschnellen kleinen Quadrokopter,
die mehr so raketenförmig sind und die Propeller hinten haben,
die können halt superschnell fliegen und die stehen mehr oder weniger so überall
einsatzbereit rum und wenn es halt irgendeine anfliegende Drohnerakete oder so gibt,
dann werden die halt schnell gestartet, können da hinterher fliegen mit hoher Geschwindigkeit.
Und dann durch Kollision vernichten.
Also in diesem Zeitraum von fünf, sechs Wochen wurde berichtet von 33.000 abgeschossenen UAVs,
also Flugobjekten irgendeiner Art Russlands, die in die Ukraine eingedrungen
sind. Und das ist nicht wenig.
Also das ist mal so locker 500 pro Tag.
Das ist ja...
Ein Ding, womit sie auch experimentieren, hast du wahrscheinlich auch gesehen,
ist diese Antonov, dieses Propellerflugzeug, wo sie diese Drohnen außen dran
gehängt haben, irgendwie vier Stück jeweils unter der Tragfläche.
Und damit dann in der Lage sind,
wenn jetzt was geortet wird,
dort hinzufliegen oder in die Nähe zu fliegen und dann die Drohnen direkt vom
Flugzeug aus zu starten, was natürlich auch noch energetisch vorteilhaft ist,
weil du schon in der Höhe bist und schon Geschwindigkeit hast.
Das heißt, damit kannst du dann auch nochmal die Reichweite oder generell Flugdynamik.
Verbessern oder auch in größeren Höhen Ziele bekämpfen, weil du die Drohnen
schon nach oben bringst und die dann nicht erstmal die 1000 oder 2000 Meter
mit ihren Batterien überwinden müssen. Das fand ich sehr interessant.
Unklar ist, in welchem Ausmaß das stattfindet und ob das jetzt mehr als nur
ein Experiment war, aber,
es scheint zumindest ein erfolgreiches Experiment gewesen zu sein und würde
mich nicht wundern, wenn das dann in Zukunft auch vielleicht mit anderen,
Flugzeugen oder eventuell große Drohnen,
die dann kleinere Drohnen zur Luftabwehr diesmal dann vielleicht auch noch ausschicken,
das halte ich auch für möglich.
Also auf jeden Fall sehr interessante Entwicklung dort.
Ja.
Einigen fällt mir gerade noch ein, auf das ich aufmerksam geworden bin.
Ich weiß nicht, inwieweit du mit dieser deutschen Firma Helsing vertraut bist.
Die haben unter anderem, also es ist ein deutsches Rüstungs-Startup,
jetzt mit einer Valuation von mehreren Milliarden,
also sozusagen ein Unicorn, die dann, die gar nicht klassisch aus der Rüstungsecke
kommen, sondern die aus der Softwareecke kommen.
Die haben halt angefangen mit AI-Software, die zu verkaufen für verschiedene
existierende Systeme und haben dann aber einen Börsengang hingelegt,
eine Finanzierung in ziemlicher Höhe,
also hunderte von Millionen an Kapital eingesammelt,
und dann eben auch selber Drohnen hergestellt bzw.
Drohnenherstellungssysteme dann auch.
Und planen eben jetzt auch so einen Loyal Wingman.
Also sie haben den bayerischen Flugzeugbauer grob gekauft und planen jetzt in
den nächsten zwei Jahren.
Eben eine KI-Drohne, eine größere, an den Start zu bringen.
Ja, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, was ich von denen halten soll.
Also, was ich so gehört habe, lässt so gewisse Alarmglocken bei mir klingeln.
So...
Warum?
Naja, die eine Sache war, dass die Ukrainer wohl mit den Drohnen,
die geliefert wurden, nicht so zufrieden waren.
Also, dass diese KI nicht so gut funktioniert, wie behauptet.
Und so, alles auch mit Vorsicht zu genießen, Wettbewerb und so.
Aber deren erste Drohnen, die da geliefert wurden, waren wohl nicht so der Kracher.
Keine Ahnung, ob das besser geworden ist. Und jetzt für eben diese neue Drohnenentwicklung,
ich glaube, die Hardware kriegen sie hin, also grob dieser Flugzeugbauer.
Also ich glaube, da sind gute Ingenieure dort, die das halt hinkriegen.
Ich weiß noch nicht, ob die Software, ob ich dieser KI,
von der dort die Rede ist, ob
man dem trauen kann und ob man einem KI-Software-Startup zuzutrauen ist.
In diesem Bereich Erfolg zu haben.
Vielleicht, ich würde es hoffen, aber wie gesagt, so ein paar Signale und auch deren.
Zeitpläne nicht vollkommen unrealistisch, aber es ist jetzt nicht so ein Elon
Musk Ausmaß an völlig unrealistischen Versprechungen,
aber für jetzt Rüstungstechnik trotzdem alles sehr ambitioniert, was sie vorhaben.
Aber jetzt im Ukraine-Krieg erstmal gemischte Erfahrungen gemacht haben.
Im Ukraine-Krieg gemischte Erfahrungen. Aber ja,
dieser Krieg bietet natürlich gerade Gelegenheit für alle möglichen Firmen dort mit ihren Produkten,
die validieren zu lassen unter realen Bedingungen und nicht immer.
Und offenbar funktioniert alles so gut, wie es in der Werbeboschüre steht.
Zumindest am Anfang nicht. Also ich meine, wo kann man das jetzt besser verbessern als dort.
Aber ich wollte nochmal zurückkommen auf, was die Ukraine selbst produziert
und welche Gewichtungen jetzt hier gelegt werden.
Also wo jetzt gerade ein richtiger Schwerpunkt drauf liegt, sind die Ground
Vehicles, also die UGVs, die Unmanned Ground Vehicles.
Das sind im Wesentlichen so kleine Tracked-Minitransporter, die halt durchs
Gelände gut vorankommen.
Also teilweise wahrscheinlich auch mit Rädern, es gibt da alles.
Die werden ja benutzt zum Beispiel für die Versorgung an der Front und auch
für die Evakuierung von verwundeten Soldaten, weil die können halt dann übers offene Feld fahren.
Und klar, die können natürlich von der Drohne vielleicht zerstört werden,
aber da stirbt denen sozusagen erstmal keiner.
Und die Ukraine hat gesagt, sie wollen also jetzt mal locker 50 Prozent ihrer
Frontlogistik mit solchen Systemen demnächst durchführen.
Also da ist auch eine ganze Menge Dynamik drin.
Und dann kommt aber natürlich auch einiges aus dem Ausland.
Neues, ganz frisch auf dem News-Kanal aufgeschlagen ist die Einigung mit Schweden.
Das jetzt, jetzt habe ich die Zahlen leider nicht ganz im Kopf,
aber eine größere Teilmenge zweistellig von Gripen, Kampfflugzeugen aus Schweden, werden geklappt.
Die werden erstmal geliefert werden, relativ bald, an die Ukraine.
Da haben wir schon ein paar Mal drüber gesprochen, wir müssen auch jetzt nicht alles wiederholen,
was dieses Flugzeug ausmacht, aber es ist halt insofern eine interessante Waffe
für die Ukraine, weil sie halt erstmal nicht aus den USA kommt.
Derzeit hat man ja lange Zeit auf die F-16 gesetzt.
Jetzt sind sich natürlich alle auch ein bisschen unsicher, wie das so weiterläuft
mit den USA und den von ihnen verkauften Waffen.
Wie lange kann man sich da noch drauf verlassen?
Deswegen orientiert sich die Ukraine jetzt sehr nach Schweden um.
Übrigens Kanada auch. Auch Kanada setzt jetzt auf Gripenfighter.
Da werden also die Amerikaner auf jeden Fall eine Menge Verkäufe verlieren und
Schweden geht es da ganz gut.
Diese Gripen gibt es in verschiedenen Generationen, die sind so mit ABCDE durchnummeriert,
das neueste ist halt E, was jetzt irgendwie kommen soll und auch da will wohl
die Ukraine sehr groß zuschlagen und sich damit modernisieren.
Also es sieht ganz so aus, als ob das jetzt so ein bisschen neben der F-16 das
wichtigste Kampfflugzeug werden könnte, was die Ukraine so betreibt und das
macht meiner Meinung nach auch Sinn.
Denn die Gripen ist ja für die Bedürfnisse in Schweden entwickelt worden und
die Bedürfnisse in Schweden sind halt teilweise doch sehr tickungsgleich mit
den Bedürfnissen der Ukraine.
Also großes Land, nicht überall Infrastruktur, man kann diese Gripen sehr günstig
fliegen, man zahlt also deutlich weniger für eine Betriebsstunde und was noch viel wichtiger ist,
das Ding kann eigentlich so auf jeder halbwegs befestigten Straße landen,
hat also keine großen Anforderungen an Flughäfen und hat auch keine großen Anforderungen
an Support-Infrastruktur, die vor Ort sein muss.
Für so einen F-16 braucht man immer einen voll ausgerüsteten Flughafen mit Hightech-Service-Modulen,
während die Gripen von vornherein im Design so entworfen worden ist,
dass man halt hier mit einem mobilen Team, was da irgendwo mit einem Transporter
aufläuft, mal eben so eine Gripen servicen kann.
Und das ist natürlich für die Ukraine super, weil das bedeutet auch,
du kannst die Dinger quasi überall verstecken und überall landen und muss nicht
vorher bekannt geben, wo das Ding irgendwie runterkommt.
Ja, also das ist definitiv ein großer Move.
Überhaupt merkt man, wie jetzt so langsam, und du hast es ja auch schon gesagt
mit Rheinmetall, wie also jetzt diese europäische Militärtechnikindustrie hochfährt.
Das hat gedauert, aber jetzt nach vier Jahren Krieg und nach initialem Zögern merkt man,
wie dieser Apparat langsam ins Laufen kommt und die Produktionsmengen machen
kann und sich auch in zunehmendem Maße auf modernere Systeme konzentriert.
Und dabei ist natürlich die Ukraine im Prinzip auch der Taktgeber.
Nicht nur, weil da jetzt so viel Bedarf ist, sondern weil sie einfach durch
ihre technologischen Entwicklungen hier auch einfach ganz klar den Weg zeigen, wohin die Reise geht.
Bei der Gripen gibt es eigentlich noch so das Detail,
dass das Haupttriebwerk, glaube ich, es kommt aus der USA und als Kanada jetzt
damit gedroht hat, quasi lieber gräpen,
zu kaufen, kam dann wohl aus den USA, dass Trump dann angeblich,
die Exportlizenzen für die Triebwerke an Kanada verweigern will, wenn,
Kanada nicht gleichzeitig auch alle F-35 Fighter abkauft von den USA, aber schauen wir mal.
Ich glaube, das amerikanische Triebwerk wird nicht mehr lange in der Griepen drin sein.
Ja.
Da gibt es ja auch noch andere Hersteller, habe ich gehört.
Ja, Russland wiederum hat nicht viel zu bieten. Also in diesem ganzen Drohnenkrieg,
da können die irgendwie nicht so richtig mithalten.
Das wird auch breit beklagt. Das Einzige, was sie jetzt immer wieder noch aus
dem Hut zaubern können, ist ihre Oreschnik-Rakete.
Sprengstofffrei durch die Gegend zu schicken. Das ist halt so eine Riesenrakete,
die eigentlich für nukleare Bedrohungen gedacht ist.
Und davon hatten sie ja schon mal eine irgendwo in Saporischer Kasson runtergehen lassen.
Und jetzt kamen, glaube ich, gleich zwei zum Einsatz, die so eine südlich von
Kiew und eine irgendwo in Rakiv runtergekommen ist, irgendwo auf dem Land,
da wusste man gar nicht genau wo,
die also jetzt keine nukleare Explosion hervorgebracht hat, weil es quasi...
Die schicken halt dieses sauteure Teil einfach los, so nach dem Motto,
guck mal, was wir theoretisch verschicken könnten,
ohne dass das jetzt irgendwelche nennenswerten Auswirkungen hat,
geschweige denn den Krieg in irgendeiner Form dreht.
Und das, ja, führte zu Aufregung nicht nur das, sondern vieles,
aber auch das führte zu einer Menge Aufregung bei den russischen Millbloggern.
Der Begriff Millblogger heißt Leute, die in irgendeiner Form diesen Krieg online begleiten,
derer gibt es ja so einige und was sie aber alle so gemeinsam haben in der letzten
Zeit, dass sie offensichtlich alle ganz schlechte Laune haben gerade.
Also jede Woche kommt eigentlich irgendwie so eine Meldung oder zumindest ein
Kommentar in einem Telegram-Kanal bis hin zu längeren Videos,
wo die sich ausführlich zu der Situation äußern und das klingt gar nicht gut.
Also da wird permanent Klage erhoben, das ging im März los.
Das ist Kritik an der Kriegsführung Putins oder beziehungsweise an der Kriegsführung
generell, aber eben auch speziell bis hin zu Rücktrittsforderungen an Putin.
Also da haben die teilweise schon wirklich die Schnauze voll und sagen halt
einfach Russland sei derzeit einfach diesem Drohnenkrieg der Ukraine einfach nicht gewachsen.
Man würde jetzt einfach gerade an der Front den Kürzeren ziehen.
Es gäbe quasi keine Möglichkeit für die Russen mit irgendwie vertretbarem Aufwand noch voranzukommen.
Auch wenn sie hier und da mal den einen oder anderen Quadratkilometer von der
Ukraine übergeben bekommen, ist im Wesentlichen, wie wir schon eingangs dargelegt haben.
Mit wenig Erfolgen hier zu rechnen und es wird in zunehmendem Maße schwieriger.
Und es ist halt jetzt so, dass eben diese Blase, die ja eigentlich total pro
Russland, pro Krieg, anti-Ukraine ist, dass die eigentlich am lautesten wimmert.
Das ist wirklich krass zu sehen.
Vielleicht noch kurz zur Oreschnik.
Das Ganze ist ja, wie du richtig gesagt hast, so eine etwas abgespeckte Interkontinentalrakete,
also etwas geringere Reichweite von, ich weiß nicht, ein paar tausend Kilometern.
Und eben, ja, die scheint sehr ungenau zu sein.
Also es ist im Prinzip 60er-Jahre-Technologie, die da wohl verbaut ist.
Und was ich so gesehen habe, die Genauigkeit scheint irgendwo in der Gegend
zwischen 500 und 1000 Metern zu liegen, was natürlich irgendwie, ja,
nur so bedingt brauchbar ist.
Und diese Metallgeschosse, die da drin sind,
die also keinen Sprengstoff enthalten, kommen allerdings mit einer sehr hohen
Geschwindigkeit an und haben ungefähr die Hälfte der Energie.
Also wenn Sprengstoff drin wäre, würde da doppelt so viel Energie freigesetzt
beim Einschlag. Es ist aber auch noch sehr abhängig davon dann natürlich,
wo die Dinger einschlagen.
Also es gab dann wohl auch Einschläge, wo man dann sah, dass das Geschoss irgendwie
einfach im Erdboden ein Loch gemacht hat und das war es.
Also kein Krater, kein nichts, einfach nur so ein kleines Loch irgendwo im Garten.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, wenn das Ding jetzt auf irgendein Gebäude oder so
trifft, dann sind die Schäden schon erheblich.
Ja, aber es ist halt für die Bekämpfung von militärischen Zielen aufgrund der
Ungenauigkeit auch eigentlich nicht geeignet, weil es ist halt eigentlich eine Atomrakete,
wo es jetzt nicht so wichtig ist, ob du jetzt 500 Meter Ungenauigkeit hast.
Aber wenn du jetzt genau das Gegenteil hast, nämlich innerte Sprengköpfe,
sondern innerte Metallstücke da drin hast,
dann müsstest du eigentlich eine hohe Präzision haben.
Und die Dinger kosten wohl auch noch pro Stück um die 30 Millionen oder so.
Das heißt, es ist halt auch jedes Mal immer schwierig zu sagen, was das kostet.
Aber in der Größenordnung weiß man, weil das ist halt eine große Rakete.
Die ist nicht billig. Und das dazu und darüber haben dann eben aber auch diese
russischen Militärblogger gelästert mit eben Fotos von Einschlägen,
wo dann einfach nichts passiert ist, die halt kaum Schäden angerichtet haben.
Aber wie gesagt, ja.
Ja, und jetzt noch zu dem Thema quasi Widerstand gegen Putin oder so.
Der kommt vor allem von rechts, weil links geschätzt, also jetzt sagen die klassischen
Dissidenten, die irgendwie eine Demokratie gerne hätten,
oder das ist irgendwo 5 bis 10 Prozent der Bevölkerung marginalisiert ohne Führungspersonen oder so.
Also diese klassische Opposition oder die Opposition, die wir uns wünschen würden,
ist halt marginalisiert.
Das heißt, wenn es zu einem Putsch käme, ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit größer,
dass irgendwie da was von rechts kommt, als dass da irgendwelche Demokraten jetzt aufstehen.
Ja, nee. Also...
Demokraten gibt es keine in Russland, zumindest keine, die irgendwelchen nennenswerten
Einfluss haben und in irgendeiner Form da Kräfte mobilisieren könnten,
die sich gegen diesen Staat richten können.
Aber was halt diese Panik der Millblogger ganz gut zeigt, ist,
dass sich was ändert in der Wahrnehmung des Krieges in Russland auf allen Seiten.
Das betrifft auch die Bevölkerung und es betrifft auch Putin selber.
Weil wenn man sich jetzt sein Treiben so anschaut in den letzten Monaten,
dann kriegt man schon das Gefühl,
dass der Typ seine Paranoia nochmal so richtig auf elf gedreht hat.
Und das hat damit zu tun, dass so seine genauen Aufenthaltsorte geheim gehalten werden.
Keiner weiß eigentlich, wo er wirklich ist.
Er hat ja so mehrere Paläste in verschiedenen Stellen in Russland, aber es wird gemunkelt,
er habe in jedem dieser Paläste einen identischen Büroraum,
der sozusagen immer gleich aussieht und wo er so seine gefilmten Botschaften
von veröffentlicht, Aber da halt
exakt derselbe Raum in der identischen Nachbildung überall vorhanden ist,
ist das allein erstmal kein Indiz dafür,
wo er denn jetzt gerade wohl war zum Zeitpunkt dieser Aufnahme oder vielleicht
auch einer Live-Übertragung. Weiß ich jetzt nicht so genau.
Ja, und er scheint auch wohl mental abzubauen, so wie Trump, also verschiedene...
Aktionen oder Sprüche von ihm, also die beiden werden sich auch ein bisschen
immer ähnlicher in ihrem Altersstarrsinn.
Ich meine, ich verfolge ja jetzt nicht Wort für Wort, was er sagt,
aber sein ganzes Auftreten hat also noch sehr viel staatsbinderische Verhalten,
was er da an den Tag legt, als man das jetzt von Trump kennt.
Aber du magst recht haben.
Was es ja, aber Wlad Wechsler meinte, gegenüber früher, wo er sich dann gerne
noch generiert hat, was weiß ich, mit nacktem Oberkörper auf dem Pferd und so und einfach aktiv war,
scheint er einfach auch jetzt, was jetzt so körperliche Aktivität angeht und
seine Gesundheit und Ernährung und Stress und so ist, Und Alter natürlich.
Ich meine, er ist halt auch nicht mehr der Jüngste, aber er hat halt offenbar
zusätzlich jetzt wohl stark mental abgebaut,
meinte eben Wechsler, der ihn seit vielen, vielen Jahren kennt und nun auch
russisch versteht und dann auch mehr die Feinheiten oder Details seines Auftretens.
Und zwischendurch, man gab ja immer wieder Krisen, wenn man sich noch erinnert,
wo er sich da, zum Beispiel als Herr Scheugu abgesetzt hat, wo er sich da die
ganze Zeit am Tisch festgehalten hat.
Oder generell so körperliche Marotten, die halt mehr und mehr werden.
Aber man ist nicht so, dass er jetzt kurz vom Exitus-Statepunkt ist.
Er ist halt auch nicht mehr also er baut ab, sagen wir es mal so er baut ab
und das ist auch nicht verwunderlich, denke ich mal das ist nur normal.
74 ist er jetzt.
Ja, aber Eigentlich kein Alter.
Na, weiß ich nicht. Ich war da noch nicht, von daher kann ich da nicht viel drüber berichten.
Mit der medizinischen Versorgung, die er eigentlich genießen darf,
hat man auf jeden Fall eine Chance.
Ja, also es gibt Leute, die mit 90 noch einen Marathon laufen,
aber Putin gehört nicht dazu. Nicht mehr dazu.
Soweit wir das wissen. Ja, so genauer kennen wir seine Aktivitäten nicht.
Naja, auf jeden Fall Paranoia scheint aber am Start zu sein.
Und das hat man daran gemerkt, dass es im März auf einmal so eine zweimöchige,
Abschaltung des Internets auf Mobilfunknetzen gab.
Und zwar in Moskau und in St. Petersburg dann auch.
Also in den beiden großen, wichtigen Zentren Russlands.
War dann auf einmal, ja, kein Netz.
Also Netz schon, aber kein Internet, also Daten wurden nicht mehr angeboten
man konnte noch telefonieren und das war es dann auch,
naja das hat die Bevölkerung jetzt nicht so begeistert, aber führte jetzt auch
nicht gleich zu Protesten aber es wussten halt alle irgendwie schon Bescheid da hat irgendjemand,
wohl Angst, das ist so ein bisschen so die Schlussfolgerung die ich rausgehört
habe dass das hier einfach eine Reaktion von Putin war, um in irgendeiner Form,
um einen Putsch oder sonst wie Aufstand zu verhindern.
Also es ist nicht so, dass es gar kein Internet mehr gab. Es gab es halt nur
zu Hause, aber eben nicht mobil.
Und das riecht natürlich schon mal stark danach, dass hier irgendjemand verhindern
wollte, dass Leute sich mobil auf der Straße in irgendeiner Form koordinieren,
wie man das irgendwie aus Miral kannte.
Die offizielle Begründung war, dass sich ukrainische Drohnen ins russische Mobilfunknetz
einwählen wählen und dann nach Hause telefonieren und auf diese Art und Weise dann,
ferngesteuert werden. Ist jetzt auch nicht von der Hand zu weisen,
aber ich gehe mal davon aus,
dass die neueren Systeme auch multi-homingfähig sind,
dass sie verschiedene Kommunikationskanäle haben,
weil du dich nicht hundertprozentig auf eine von denen verlassen kannst,
auf Mobilfunk als sein, dass es dann in Brandenburg ist oder so,
und keine Verbindung hat, obwohl das auch besser geworden ist jetzt hier.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass Russland flächendeckend mit Mobilfunk versorgt ist
und auf der anderen Seite ja Satelliten.
Denke ich mal, dass sie auch das Starlink Mini jetzt, beziehungsweise ist ja
jetzt so klein geworden mittlerweile,
dass das auch jetzt auf Drohnen passt und auch sogar, dass die Russen es ja
auch auf Drohnen montiert haben und die Ukrainer tun das sicherlich,
Auch ständig. Ich habe auch Gerüchte gehört, ich weiß nicht, ob das Propaganda war,
aber dass die Ukrainer bei Electronic Warfare so ein System selbst entwickelt
haben, eine ukrainische Firma,
was halt einfach extrem gut funktioniert.
Das was tun soll?
Das ist in der Lage, alle möglichen Dinge zu tun.
Eine Sache ist halt GPS-Spoofing bzw.
Manipulation oder einfach sämtliche Kommunikation komplett lahmzulegen und zwar auf,
In zig Kilometern Entfernung angeblich. Und das Problem ist aber,
dass es wohl so effektiv sein soll, dass wenn sie das einsetzen,
nichts mehr funktioniert.
Also auch die eigene Kommunikation dann unterbunden wird.
Aber dass sie auf diese Art und Weise in der Lage waren,
die Gefahr durch russische Gleitbomben extrem zu eliminieren,
weil sie im Prinzip die Gleitbomben dann mehr oder weniger übernommen haben
oder die so weit ab dann vom Ziel gebracht haben,
dass dieser Threat, der mal existierte,
extrem zurückgegangen ist aufgrund von Electronic Warfare.
Schwer zu sagen, klingt sehr fantastisch, aber ja.
Genau, aber um mal wieder bei Putin zu landen, da ist schon.
So eine Angst im Raum. Also man kann zwischen den Zeilen rauslesen,
dass er keine guten Antworten auf die aktuelle Situation hat.
Also er kann den Krieg derzeit der Gesellschaft nicht verkaufen.
Er sieht sich zu Maßnahmen gezwungen, die hochgradig unpopulär sind.
Die Abschaltung von Telegram, das Blockieren von VPNs, all diese ganzen Maßnahmen,
damit macht er sich keine Freunde.
Nicht, dass er jetzt viele neue Freunde unbedingt bräuchte und ich sage auch
nicht, weil jetzt Telegram abgeschaltet ist, wird die russische Gesellschaft
die Revolution ausrufen.
Davon sind wir glaube ich sehr weit entfernt, aber es zeigt eben eine Unsicherheit
und das ist natürlich auch etwas, was von der Ukraine propagandamäßig ganz gut
ausgeschlachtet werden kann,
weil das ist ja auch wichtig, wie dieser Krieg und dieser Konflikt und die Stärke
der Ukraine wahrgenommen wird.
Und es hat sich natürlich super geil gezeigt, als dann am 9.
Mai Putin wieder seine jährliche Superparade abfeiern wollte.
Da wird ja dann immer der Sieg gegen Deutschland gefeiert, den großen Vaterländischen
Krieg, was wir Zweiten Weltkrieg nennen.
Und da gibt es dann immer fette Parade und dann fahren da stundenlang Panzer
rauf und runter und Flugzeuge fliegen über den Platz vor dem Kreml.
Und was nicht alles, also endlose Präsentationen und der steht da stundenlang
und winkt. Dieses Jahr war es anders.
Erstmal war dann erstmal wieder so vorher so eine Diskussion mit,
ja jetzt könnten wir ja mal drei Tage Waffnstillstand machen.
Wo die Ukraine so gesagt hat haltet ihr euch ja sowieso nicht dran.
Wir zählen eh nichts auf euer Wort also geht mal woanders hin hat aber dann
die ganze Aufregung, die ganze Diskussion dann um diese Parade und wie wird
die denn jetzt so stattfinden super genutzt indem,
ein Dekret veröffentlicht hat also ein offizielles Dekret des Präsidenten der
Ukraine, so hast du das gesehen, dieses Blatt Grandios,
dass er Putin erlaubt, an diesem Tag diese Parade durchzuführen.
Und zwar mit so den konkreten GPS-Koordinaten des Rechtecks dieses Platzes, wo das dann erlaubt ist.
Da dürft ihr das dann machen, da greifen wir euch nicht an, da seid ihr dann sicher.
Also wirklich ein geiler Schenkelklopfer. Und ja, am Ende war es so,
dass halt diese Parade sehr lächerlich abgelaufen ist.
Es waren überhaupt gar keine Fahrzeuge mehr dabei, also keine Panzer,
keine geschützten Militärfahrzeuge in irgendeiner Art, keine Flugzeuge.
Und alles, was gezeigt wurde im Fernsehen, wurde dann noch ergänzt um Videoaufnahmen davon.
Also man hat dann so, ja, Flugzeuge haben wir auch, die fliegen da durch die
Luft und so. Aber die flogen halt nicht in dem Moment über den Krimmel.
Wahrscheinlich, weil die sich nicht
so ohne weiteres in dem von Silenskyer GPS-Rechteck aufhalten konnten.
Nee, also die Theorien waren andere, warum dort auch keine Flugzeuge waren, weil die Fürchtung war,
was, wenn einer der Piloten auf dumme Ideen kommt.
Das kann auch gut sein, dass seine Paranoia so weit schon geht.
Jaja, das wird vermutet, das sozusagen.
Und der andere Grund, warum keine Fahrzeuge da waren, war die Befürchtung,
also wenn jetzt Leute da rumstehen und jetzt ein Drohnenangriff kommt,
die können schnell abhauen, die können wegrennen und sich zerstreuen.
Aber die Fahrzeuge kämen dann nicht weg.
Und wenn dann halt so ein Fahrzeug auf der Paradestrecke getroffen würde und
dann dort liegen bleibt, das war sozusagen die Befürchtung,
warum man dann keine Fahrzeuge dort hat aufmarschieren lassen.
Und mit dem Waffenstillstellen war es so,
Vorher noch, also Putin hat wohl irgendwie über Trump für den Tag der Parade
irgendwie Waffenstillstand haben wollen,
woraufhin Zelensky dann sagte, ach Waffenstillstand ist super,
aber dann lass uns doch irgendwie gleich drei Tage machen.
Und hat dann halt vorgeschlagen, ja wenn Waffenstillstand, dann machen wir doch
lieber gleich drei Tage und hat dann eben einen eigenen Termin genannt für den Waffenstillstand,
von wann bis wann der stattfinden sollte, nämlich zwei Tage vor der Parade.
Und natürlich war klar dann, dass Russland diesen Waffenstillstand natürlich
nicht respektiert hat, sodass Zelensky dann noch sagen konnte,
wir haben ja einen Waffenstillstand hier vorgeschlagen, wir waren bereit,
aber Russland hat sich nicht an den Waffenstillstand gehalten,
also brauchen wir uns auch nicht dran zu halten.
Das war noch so der andere Twist.
Und dann kam eben noch diese Nummer mit, ja, okay, ihr dürft hier eure Parade abhalten.
Und es waren auch nicht viele ausländische Gäste angereist.
Also das war die andere Sache.
Die Teilnahme war wohl sehr, sehr spärlich an zugereisten Gästen.
Da wollte keiner so richtig dabei sein. Dafür gab es aber nordkoreanische Soldaten,
die diesmal auflaufen durften. Das war auch ein First.
Naja, also auf jeden Fall war das eine ziemlich peinliche Parade aus Perspektive von Putin.
Also wenig von dem gezeigt werden, was er normalerweise dort gerne öffentlich zur Schau trägt.
An seiner Stelle, also an sich war das eine vernünftige Sache.
Noch vernünftiger wäre es gewesen, die Parade komplett abzusagen,
weil vernünftige Länder machen keine Militärparaden aus guten Gründen.
Weil das ist halt Verschwendung von Zeit und Geld und Ressourcen und die Soldaten
haben da nicht so richtig Bock drauf und also niemand,
der halbwegs bei Verstand ist, hat großen Bock auf riesige Militärparaden.
Ja gut, vielleicht mal zum 100-jährigen Jubiläum oder so könnte man das vielleicht mal machen.
Aber generell gibt es einen guten Grund, warum Militärparaden aus der Mode geraten sind.
Und Trump hat ja dann versucht, aber wollte ja dann auch eine veranstalten oder
hat dann eine veranstaltet.
Ich glaube auch, dass er das nicht ein zweites Mal probiert,
so wie das da gelaufen ist dann mit der...
Mit Trumps Parade.
Also insofern, ja, hätte ich mir eher gewünscht im Sinne der Ukraine,
wenn er irgendwie alles aufgefahren hätte, was er hat, einfach aus taktischen Gründen.
Ja, also ist ein Auslaufmodell, die Militärparade.
Kann man sagen. Ja, was macht das jetzt mit der Gesellschaft und vor allem was
macht das mit der russischen Wirtschaft?
Da sind die Nachrichten auch nicht besonders gut für Russland.
Wir haben ja schon erwähnt, dass jetzt durch diese Schläge auf die Ölinfrastruktur
die größte Einnahmequelle dahin ist. Eine weitere wichtige Einnahmequelle sprudelt
ja auch schon seit vier Jahren nicht mehr, nämlich es gibt keine Militärexporte mehr Russlands.
Also man hat zwar glaube ich dem Iran das eine oder andere noch zugestellt,
aber so generell große Bestellungen gibt es derzeit nicht, weil ja Russland
alles für sich selber braucht.
Und ja, durch den Krieg ist natürlich jetzt auch die Gesellschaft und die Wirtschaft
enorm unter Druck geraten.
Putin hat jetzt sogar schon die Oligarchen aufgefordert, sich doch auch irgendwie
nochmal an den Kriegskosten zu beteiligen. Das klingt schon etwas verzweifelt.
Es wurde die Umsatzsteuer angehoben
und überhaupt steigt halt die Ausgabenlast für die Russen ohnehin.
Da sind die so ein bisschen dran gewöhnt an solche Schwankungen.
Trotzdem ist die Situation nicht gut.
Wir hatten das schon mehrfach erwähnt, dass dieser große Sozialfonds,
den sich Russland eigentlich beiseite gelegt hat für schwere Zeiten,
um ihm sicherzustellen, dass Renten gezahlt werden können etc.,
der ist weitgehend aufgebraucht.
Ich denke, der ist jetzt dieses Jahr dann auch durch. Und mittlerweile verkauft
Russland sogar seine Goldbestände, um irgendwie noch Geld reinzubeholen.
Dieser Boom, der scheinbare Boom durch diese Umstellung auf Militärproduktion,
der ja sozusagen auch viele dann wieder in die Militärindustrie,
in diese Produktionsindustrie reingezogen hat und dann berührt.
Quasi gefühlt für die Leute, auch für so einen zwischenzeitlichen Boom gesorgt hat.
Das hat halt nur dazu geführt, dass diese Einkommen dann angehoben wurden,
weil sie eben mithalten mussten mit diesen Vergütungen, die an Soldaten ausgezahlt werden.
Jetzt wo das Geld dafür schon nicht mehr da ist,
sinken diese Einkommen jetzt auch wieder und dieser ganze demografische Rückgang,
dass sozusagen so viele junge Männer jetzt in den Krieg ziehen und dort sterben,
führt also in zunehmendem Maße dazu, dass einfach die Leute auf dem Arbeitsmarkt fehlen.
Da gibt es Schätzungen von ungefähr 2,5 Millionen Leuten, die man also durchaus
in irgendeiner Form beschäftigen könnte, die einfach nicht mehr da sind.
Und dieser Mangel an Männern führt sogar dazu, dass auch die Frauen sich jetzt
im Ausland orientieren, weil es halt einfach keine Männer mehr gibt,
mit denen man in irgendeiner Form eine Partnerschaft aufbauen kann.
Das führt also zu so einer Unzufriedenheit, auch die Repressionen,
auch diese Internetabschaltung, all das akkumuliert sich.
Die Leute können das jetzt nicht in so eine Revolution kanalisieren,
aber es ist halt einfach eine steigende wirtschaftliche Not.
Gut 40 bis 50 Prozent des Einkommens müssen sie irgendwie für Lebensmittel ausgeben,
die immer teurer werden.
Und es gab eine Umfrage in Russland, wie denn so die Zustimmungsrate sei zu
Putin, inwiefern man sozusagen noch seine Politik unterstütze.
Und die Zahl kam auf 66 Prozent raus. Das ist jetzt für so eine Diktatur schon
mal ein sehr schlechter Wert, würde ich sagen.
Weil die stimmt bestimmt nicht und ist trotzdem niedrig.
Ja, ja, ja. Die andere Sache ist, was ich gehört habe, ist, dass auch die Art
und Weise, wie die Zustimmungsquote jetzt erhoben wird, geändert wurde.
Und zwar war es vorher, dass man das telefonisch gemacht hat,
wie üblich Telefonumfragen irgendwie.
Und jetzt?
Aber die Ergebnisse waren wohl nicht so ideal.
Und dann hat man gesagt, dass jetzt die Leute persönlich an der Tür befragt werden.
Und da kommen dann so drei...
Leute klingeln dann bei dir an der Tür und fragen dich, was du denn so von Putin hältst.
Und trotzdem sagen ein Drittel der Russen, ja, finde ich jetzt nicht so gut.
Und wie du schon richtig sagst, man muss immer gucken, wie sind denn diese Zustimmungsquoten,
Wie kommen die denn da zustande?
Aber eine Mehrheit der Russen hat Putin vermutlich schon noch hinter sich,
beziehungsweise sind die halt dermaßen depolitisiert.
Dass Putin oder die Regierung, wer da regiert, das ist eh so eine Naturgewalt.
Das ist sozusagen, ja, ob da jetzt gerade, ja,
so wie die Mondphasen oder so, da habe ich jetzt auch keinen Einfluss drauf,
ja, das ist also, deswegen trage ich da jetzt auch keine Verantwortung für,
was meine Regierung macht.
Das ist jetzt auch keine völlig falsche Sicht und wirst du wahrscheinlich bei
vielen Leuten hier auch finden, dass sie sagen,
ich bin doch nicht verantwortlich dafür, was jetzt hier der Kanzler gerade macht oder sagt.
Da kann ich doch nichts für, was da passiert.
Wieso werde ich jetzt bombardiert? Das war dann so das Ding,
wieso bombardieren die Ukrainer uns oder mich?
Waren dann halt super empört, fanden das halt total ungerecht.
Aber aus dem Grund einfach, weil sie sich überhaupt nicht damit identifizieren,
und der Meinung sind, ja...
Das hat mit mir nichts zu tun, dieser Krieg.
Das ist halt eine weit verbreitete Haltung in Russland.
Das ist Angelegenheit der Regierung.
Da habe ich nichts mit zu tun.
Ja, das ist, genau, du beziehst dich wahrscheinlich auf dieses eine Video von
dem Russen, der nach diesen Angriffen auf Moskau sich irgendwie in so einem
Selfie-Video geäußert hat und so sein Missverständnis,
sein Unverständnis darüber abgeliefert hat und natürlich, wenn man jetzt als Außenstehender,
vor allem so aus dem Westen heraus,
sich das anschaut und sagt so, wieso greift ihr uns denn hier an?
Da fragen wir uns natürlich, habt ihr sie noch alle?
Ihr greift seit vier Jahren dieses Land an, der totale Terror und dann wundert
euch, dass da mal eine Bombe hochgeht.
Aber das drückt wahrscheinlich auch sehr gut aus, dass,
diese Leute dort einfach komplett disjunkt sind von dem, was diese Regierung macht.
Das ist für die wie ein anderes Land fast.
Ja, aber man könnte sogar Parallelen zu 9-11 ziehen, so bei den Amerikanern,
so nach dem Motto, wieso greifen die uns eigentlich an völlig grundlos?
Was haben wir denen denn getan?
Das tolle Amerika.
Ja, das stimmt. Da ist was dran und Und das wird auch schwierig sein,
wenn dieser Krieg mal vorbei ist, in irgendeiner Form da einen Konsens zu finden in diesem Land.
Also so eine Schuldanerkenntnis aller Deutschland nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
wird sich dort glaube ich nicht machen lassen.
Das kann man vergessen.
Also es gipfelt sie dann auch noch in diesem Videopost von einer Influencerin
namens Viktoria Bonja oder so.
Das ist so ein russisches Model, die wohl schon sehr lange sehr bekannt ist
in Russland. Ich kannte die natürlich nicht.
Die wohnt auch nicht in Russland, sondern die wohnt auch wie in Monaco.
Also die hat glaube ich jetzt mit den Finanzen keine großen Probleme und macht
halt was in Florenza so machen und berichtet halt über so die schöne Welt.
Aber die hatte dann auch so ein bisschen die Schnauze voll und die hat dann
so ein Dis-Video rausgebracht, wo sie wirklich mal quer über Putin und die Regierung,
was Russland derzeit alles so treibt, her erzählt und sagt, es geht ja gar nicht.
Und zwar jetzt nicht wieder mit Ukraine und was macht ihr denn da,
sondern einfach nur so, dem Land geht es jetzt nicht gut.
Wirtschaft ist schwierig, Lebensumstände
sind schwierig, ist teuer und so weiter. So diese Perspektive.
Und das Problem ist natürlich, dadurch, dass sie nicht in Russland ist,
kann sie jetzt auch nicht so ohne weiteres sanktioniert werden.
Da sie auch sehr beliebt zu sein scheint in Russland und sehr bekannt ist kann
man die jetzt nicht so die kann man dann auch nicht einfach so,
fenestrieren wie man das ja normalerweise macht in Russland,
wenn einer so ein bisschen querschlägt, also das war für.
Die Regierung sehr schwierig damit umzugehen weil sie sich da noch nicht mal
drauf beziehen konnten, sie konnten es eigentlich nur ignorieren und das,
Wurde aber dann eben trotzdem breit wahrgenommen. Zumindest bei allen,
die noch in der Lage waren, diese Kanäle zu empfangen, auf denen sie postet.
Aber da gibt es durchaus Wege.
Und insgesamt ist halt einfach, ja, das Verhältnis, glaube ich,
zwischen Staat und Gesellschaft ist im Eimer.
Und die Gesellschaft hat aber auch in zunehmendem Maße einfach keinen Bock mehr
auf den ganzen Scheiß. Das ist, wie gesagt, alles noch weit von jeglicher Revolution entfernt.
Also Widerstand nur. Auch Putin kann den Bogen nicht komplett überspannen.
Und das sind alles so kleine Dinge, die dazu beitragen, die Gesamtstimmung in
irgendeiner Form zu ändern.
Ja, da gab es dann ja auch noch den anderen Fall von diesen.
Von diesen Propagandisten, ich suche gerade mal.
Ilya Remeslo, glaube ich, genau, so ein ehemaliger Z-Blogger und krimelnaher Mill-Blogger,
der dann plötzlich drei Videos gemacht hat, wo er auch komplett über Putin und
den Zustand in Russland hergezogen ist.
Also quasi genau ein öffentliches Manifest gegen Putin und den Ukraine-Krieg veröffentlicht hat.
Und der wurde dann in die Psychiatrie Nummer 3 in Petersburg eingewiesen,
weil man meinte, er sei einfach verrückt geworden.
Weil das anders ließen sich seine Äußerungen jetzt nicht erklären,
dass er irgendwie einen psychischen Zusammenbruch hatte.
Aber in den Videos, wenn man sich die anguckt, ja, also der macht jetzt keinen
komplett verrückten Eindruck.
Und auch mit dem, was er sagte und so, hatte das jetzt nicht den Eindruck,
dass er da jetzt irgendwie an einem psychotischen Schub leidet,
sondern das Klang schon alles hatte irgendwie Hand und Fuß, von dem er erzählt hat.
Da kamen jetzt keine Aliens vor oder so, Sondern ja, das entsprach alles auch
weitgehend den Tatsachen.
Und ja.
Also weiterer Fall. Und da gab es noch mehr, die dann jetzt angefangen haben,
sich kritisch zu äußern.
Und die scheinen auch trotzdem in der Lage, also es gibt viele Leute,
die scheinen trotzdem noch mit VPN rauszukommen aus Russland.
Mit Sicherheit.
Ja, ja, ja.
Okay, dann haben wir,
glaube ich, diesen Teil ganz gut abgefrühstückt und dann sollten wir jetzt nochmal
auf das Rahmengeschehen in der internationalen Politik blicken.
Und es gab sicherlich kein krasseres Ereignis im Gesamtkontext als die Abwahl von Orban.
Dem seit 16 Jahren Regierenden und jetzt eben final abgewählten Regierungschef in Ungarn.
Und das Ganze, obwohl sogar noch J.D.
Vance kurz vorher aufgetaucht ist und versucht hat, ihn zu retten mit einem
völlig absurden Telefoninterview, was er mit Trump irgendwie auf der Bühne geführt
hat. Also es ist so albern.
Am Endergebnis, bitte?
Und einer versuchten Volksfleck-Operation, noch die Ukraine in die Schuhe geschoben werden sollte.
Es hat alles einfach nicht mehr verfangen. Die Ungarn, die ungarische Bevölkerung,
die hat einfach die Schnauze voll gehabt.
Wir waren ja beide in letzter Zeit öfter mal in Ungarn und es war ja einfach so offensichtlich.
Überall hingen so Plakate mit, oh die böse EU und Selenskyj,
ganz böse und alle haben was gegen uns.
Ursula von der Leyen und massiv Propaganda in den Straßen, Litwasssäulen,
Fernseh komplett kontrolliert.
Also sogar so weit. Ich meine, das war so schön, dass der Maiga durfte in den
letzten zwei Jahren auch überhaupt nicht im Fernsehen auftreten.
Es gab halt einen Bann oder Boykott, dass der nicht interviewt werden durfte.
Und das war so episch, als er dann das erste Mal quasi nach zwei Jahren wieder
im Staatsfernsehen zu sehen war,
hat er dann den Journalisten, der ihn geinterviewt hat, Journalisten.
Einer Journalistin.
Ah, Journalistin. Ja, dann im Prinzip gesagt, also ihr werdet alle euren Job verlieren.
Episch.
Jetzt ist Schluss mit lustig. Ihr habt mich hier seit zwei Jahren sozusagen
außen vor gehalten und ja.
Genau, also das Interview war natürlich absolutes Gold.
Er hat ihn dann irgendwie, also wirklich komplett alles aufs Brot geschmiert,
so nach dem Motto, also was ihr hier abgezogen hat, da wäre ja also Nordkorea
wäre ja da neidisch geworden, ja, so krasse Propaganda, wie ihr hier feiert.
Erstmal vielleicht nochmal so die Fakten, also die Wahl hat stattgefunden,
sie wurde offensichtlich nicht ausreichend manipuliert, am Ende hat,
Magia mit seiner wie heißt noch gleich die,
mit Tisha, mit seiner Party, also sie ist nicht wirklich neu,
aber wurde quasi von ihm so, war so ein Empty Vessel, was er dann wieder reaktiviert
hat und er hat also eine satte,
Zweidrittelmehrheit im ungarischen Parlament.
Das heißt, hier sind auch Verfassungsänderungen möglich und er hat eben umfangreiche
Reformen angekündigt in nahezu jeder Beziehung.
Er macht da durchaus eine gute Figur.
Auch die Leute, mit denen er jetzt diese Regierung bildet, das ist so,
was man so gemeinhin eine Technokratenregierung nennt.
Das heißt, er hat jetzt nicht irgendwelche Politiker gewählt,
sondern die jeweiligen Bereiche werden von ...
Experten geführt. Also, ich kenne die nicht, aber.
Die haben sich jetzt nicht durch irgendwelche politischen Aktivitäten in einer
Partei vor allem gezeigt, sondern die sind halt einfach in dem jeweiligen Feld,
haben die durchaus Kompetenz, weil ich denke, der Magier hat schon verstanden,
dass er jetzt hier sehr schnell zu sinnvollen Reformen kommen muss,
um da einfach die Dynamik des Volkes mitzunehmen.
Dazu gehört auch die Normalisierung der Beziehungen zur EU selbstverständlich
und aber auch die Normalisierung der Beziehungen zur Ukraine.
Vielleicht noch kurz zu der Wahl und der Zweidrittelmehrheit,
wie wichtig das war, weil die eine Sache ist,
dass Orban das Wahlsystem verändert hatte,
dahingehend, dass wenn man jetzt nur eine kleine Mehrheit, also eine kleine
absolute Mehrheit hat in der Zahl der Stimmen, dass das aber dazu führt,
dass man leichter eine Zweidrittelmehrheit kriegt, weil die wollten sich diese
Zweidrittelmehrheit sichern und haben dann den Großteil der Gesetze,
die sie verabschiedet haben,
waren sogenannte priorisierte Gesetze, die auch nur mit einer Zweidrittelmehrheit
wieder geändert werden dürften.
Das heißt, deren Kalkül war, dass selbst wenn sie mal irgendwie die Macht verlieren,
dass dann ihre Gesetze bleiben, solange die anderen nicht auch zwei Drittel kriegen.
Nur was ihnen halt, ich weiß nicht, ob ihnen das klar war oder nicht,
aber dass ihre Manipulationen am Wahlsystem jetzt dazu geführt haben,
aber auch, dass jetzt die Opposition.
Die ehemalige Opposition auch nur, auch jetzt nicht zwei Drittel der Stimmen
brauchte, sondern durchaus weniger, um jetzt zwei Drittel der Parlamentssitze zu erhalten.
Und das ist halt auch das Interessante am sogenannten Gerrymandering,
was ja in den USA das große Thema ist, also Wahlkreise so zuzuschneiden, dass jetzt...
Von sechs Wahlkreisen sorgt man dafür, dass die Wähler der Opposition alle in
ein oder zwei Wahlkreisen versammelt sind,
die sie dann kriegen, aber die anderen Wahlkreise haben dann satte Mehrheiten von deiner Partei,
um dadurch das zu zementieren.
Aber das Problem ist,
dass durch dieses Gerrymandering dann aber auch,
wie es so schön heißt, die Margins sich dann so verändern, dass wenn jetzt die
andere Seite plötzlich mehr Stimmen kriegt,
dass dann die Auswirkungen für dich negativer sind, dass du plötzlich dann mehr
Wahlkreise verlieren kannst.
Das hat jetzt stattgefunden in Ungarn, sagst du?
Und das hat in Ungarn eben jetzt stattgefunden und deswegen ist jetzt ja,
aber es ist natürlich eine Menge Arbeit nach so vielen Jahren Orbán,
das alles jetzt innen auszumisten und alles wieder in normale Bahnen zu lenken,
dürfte keine einfache Aufgabe sein.
Keine leichte Aufgabe, aber in gewisser Hinsicht, glaube ich, ist sein Ansatz auch,
Dadurch auch noch radikaler. Also jetzt gerade bei diesen Medienreformen,
die Urban dort durchgeführt hat, haben ja dazu geführt, dass er eben sozusagen
alles unter Kontrolle hat.
Und weil das einfach alles so hoffnungslos nicht mehr zu retten ist,
wird es nicht reformiert, sondern wird einfach aufgelöst.
Und ob dann was Besseres kommt, das werden wir mal sehen.
Aber jetzt sind die ersten Schritte auf jeden Fall erstmal sehr positiv.
Dieser 90 Milliarden Kredit der EU an Ukraine, der ja noch bis zuletzt von Orbán
geblockt wurde, der ist jetzt nicht mehr geblockt. Der wird jetzt stattfinden.
Das ukrainische Parlament hat jetzt auch gerade dafür gestimmt.
Das wird also jetzt fließen. Nicht alles auf einmal, sondern irgendwie über Jahre glaube ich.
Das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal gut. Was auch noch zu sehen war,
ist, dass Fizzo, der Chef der Slowakei, der ja so ein bisschen mit Orbán so
ein bisschen auf derselben Linie ist und auch einer der wenigen war,
der glaube ich noch bei Putin auf dieser Parade war.
Dass der auf einmal nicht mehr so laut tönt und auch keine Anstalten macht,
jetzt sich groß noch gegen diese Ukraine-Geschichte zu wehren.
Das kann ich jetzt nur mutmaßen, aber es macht auf mich so ein bisschen den
Eindruck, als ob er jetzt den Schuss gehört hat.
Also Orban schien ja unbesiegbar.
Im Gegenteil war der Fall und das ist natürlich für ihn auch ein Warnsignal,
wenn er denn gedenkt sich irgendwie zu halten,
weiß er, dass das jetzt nicht übertreiben darf, weil die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass die Slowakei dann genauso eine Blockade reingedrückt bekommt,
wie das mit Ungarn zuletzt der Fall war,
die ist natürlich damit enorm gestiegen, allein schon weil sozusagen ein Veto-Partner weggefallen ist.
Und von daher glaube ich, ist das generell erstmal für die EU ein ganz guter Trend.
Jetzt muss man natürlich gucken, wie das in Frankreich so weitergeht,
aber das ist ein anderes Thema.
Orban selber ist jetzt wohl in die USA abgehauen. Erst meinte er,
er würde ja noch irgendwie in der Opposition walten und so weiter.
Ich weiß nicht, ob er schon da ist, aber man hört, dass jetzt die Amerikaner
versuchen, ihn bei der UN unterzubringen, um ihm da in irgendeiner Form Immunität zu verschaffen,
weil die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass wenn er jetzt nicht abhaut,
dass sie ihn dann einknasten werden, ist ja relativ hoch.
Keine Ahnung, wie das ausgeht.
Ja, also das ist das Ungarn-Kapitel. Das werdet ihr ja auch ein bisschen mitbekommen haben.
Es ist einfach generell erstmal sehr positiv. Es gibt ja noch die guten Nachrichten.
Und was,
noch bemerkenswert ist, ist, dass ja, alles, was Trump beziehungsweise die MAGA-Bewegung
also viel von dem, was deren Playbook ist, haben sie sich halt von Ungarn abgeguckt.
Und Orbán hat auch dafür gesorgt,
sie hat ja unter anderem dieses große konservativen Treffen, CPEC, genau,
gab es halt auch eine CPEC Ungarn.
Und da haben dann so 2.000 bis 3.000 Konservative, die meisten aus den USA, dann angereist.
Und er hat das Ganze vom ungarischen Staat mit Millionen an Euro gefördert.
Also im Rahmen jetzt der Gesamtkorruption eigentlich Peanuts,
würde ich sagen, aber nichtsdestotrotz wirklich bemerkenswert,
dass der ungarische Staat Geld, also Millionen dafür ausgegeben hat,
um amerikanische Konservative zu hosten und zu indoktrinieren. mit,
ungarischen Ideen dort.
In dieser ganzen Magerbewegung ist er halt einfach auch so der absolute Superstar
gewesen und umso mehr legen sie sich jetzt halt auch aus dem Zeug,
um da seine Haut zu retten.
Ob das mit der UN funktioniert, da habe ich so ein bisschen meine Zweifel.
Aber es zeigt natürlich auch die Bedeutung dessen, dass jetzt abgewählt wurde,
wirft natürlich seinen Schatten voraus jetzt auf einmal, was denn jetzt in den USA passieren könnte.
Ich war überrascht allerdings, ich war überrascht, dass Orban dann so relativ
kampflos abgetreten ist.
Da war ja noch die Befürchtung, aber ich glaube, es war einfach zu überwältigend, der Umschwung,
dass das einfach alles andere hätte zur Katastrophe geführt.
Ja, ich glaube auch. Also wenn er sich dagegen gewehrt hätte,
dann hätten sie ihn angezündet.
Es wurden natürlich dann auch die Schredder angeworfen und so noch in den letzten Wochen.
Also hat man schon versucht, viel inkriminiertes Material zu beseitigen.
Wird man sehen, wie gut ihnen das gelungen sein wird.
Hast du dieses Video gesehen, wo der Magiar irgendwie durch dieses Innenministerium
geführt wurde mit Kamera?
Alter, das war auch so krass.
Die sind da so mit einer größeren Truppe da so rein und die ganze Zeit in der,
also wurde quasi die ganze Zeit gefilmt, wie er mit einem größeren Entourage
da durch dieses Innenministerium durchmarschiert.
Und dann alles perfekt restauriert, also teuer Geld und es dann durch diese
Lounge-Rommel, guck mal hier die Möbel, was das alles gekostet hat und so weiter.
Hat er noch irgendwelche Mülleimer noch aufgehoben und so, ja guck mal,
hier ist auch noch geschredderte Dokumente drin und so.
Also einfach eine unglaubliche Show.
Ja, und er hat, glaube ich, auch viele dieser Regierungsgebäude dann für die
Öffentlichkeit geöffnet,
dass die Bürger mal rein können und selber gucken können, wie es denn dort eigentlich aussieht.
Und so, dass also, ja, der...
Der scheint,
was auf dem Kasten zu haben auf jeden Fall und oder die richtigen Berater auch
zu haben, aber ja, es ist schon phänomenal.
Es ist auch phänomenal, wie er das geschafft hat, trotz des Medienboykotts und
geschafft hat das, indem er einfach,
hunderte von Veranstaltungen gemacht hat, auf im Prinzip in jedes ungarische
Dorf gefahren ist und dort vor den Leuten geredet hat,
weil er halt die Medien einfach nicht hatte und das scheint funktioniert zu haben.
Gut, dann schauen wir nochmal so ein bisschen auf das restliche politische Geschehen.
Also, ja, ihr wisst ja, ist ja alles ein bisschen durcheinander.
Also die Ukraine hat auf jeden Fall eine Menge an Kooperationen und Unterstützung
erhalten durch zahlreiche europäische Länder.
Die ganzen Militärkooperationen haben wir auch schon gesprochen.
Es gibt auch jetzt in zunehmendem Maße sogenannte Sicherheitspartnerschaften
mit allen möglichen Ländern. Da sind dann so Länder wie Indien dabei oder Aserbaidschan.
Also ich finde es sehr interessant, dass die Ukraine jetzt noch in dieser Situation
des Krieges es schafft, jetzt hier so ganz neue Allianzen zu schmieden.
Das mag jetzt nicht viel aussagen.
Es ist nicht so, dass jetzt Indien anfängt in Russland einzumarschieren,
weil sie jetzt gegen die Ukraine vorgegangen sind.
Ich denke, diese ganzen Sicherheitspartnerschaften haben eben sehr viel auch
mit der Drohnentechnik zu tun und mit ihren militärischen Fähigkeiten.
Das sind alles so Deals mit, aha, ihr wollt da irgendwie Einblicke haben,
ihr wollt wissen, wie man diesen Drohnenkrieg bekämpfen kann,
da können wir euch helfen, aber wir wollen das auch im Rahmen eines umfangreicheren
Kooperationsprogramms sehen.
Und dann wollen wir halt auch was dafür haben.
Und sie sind jetzt einfach in der Lage, nicht nur bei so reichen Ländern wie
den Golfstaaten oder so mächtigen Ländern wie Indien oder so.
Nah an Russland lokalisierten Ländern wie Aserbaidschan irgendwie solche Sachen
zu machen, zusätzlich zu Europa.
Und das ist, ja, das finde ich schon mal für sich bemerkenswert.
Ja, oder wie sie es dann geschafft haben, irgendwie sich in Libyen einzunisten.
Das war sicherlich auch irgendwie Diplomatie dann mit irgendwelchen einer der Fraktionen dort und so.
Sie klopfen einfach überall an, wo die Leute Russland auch nicht so geil finden.
Und das erinnert mich an,
neulich bin ich auf ein altes Essay gestoßen aus den 50er Jahren und dann auch
in den 60er Jahren, wo es um das Thema ging,
unter anderem, dass Amerika der Meinung war, seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg oder
auch vorher, dass sie halt so übermächtig sind.
Es wurde mit dem Spruch so, what Lola wants, Lola gets, sozusagen diese Geschichte.
Und dass sie dann total verwundert waren, als sie dann in Vietnam irgendwie
das nicht funktioniert hat oder in anderen Ecken auch, dass sie es überhaupt
nicht verstehen konnten, wie das sein kann, dass die Amerika verlieren kann.
Aber in dem Zusammenhang war
der Punkt dann die Frage von Verbündeten und da gab es dann den Hinweis,
dass das britische Reich.
Das britische Reich hat halt trotz seiner globalen Herrschaft und Übermacht
immer nur dann gewonnen, wenn es Verbündete hatte und verloren,
wenn es keine Verbündeten hatte.
Aber eben auch in der Regel wusste, bestimmte Dinge einfach nicht zu tun,
weil nicht genügend Verbündete da waren oder die Konstellation einfach nicht gut war.
Und in dem Fall, ja, einmal fand ich das bemerkenswert, einmal im Hinblick natürlich
auf die USA, aber jetzt auch im Hinblick auf die ukrainischen Bestrebungen,
möglichst viele Freunde zu gewinnen, weil Kriege, egal wie stark man ist,
gewinnt man nur mithilfe von Freunden. Ja, genau.
Und für die Ukraine, wenn man nicht stark ist, ist es wahrscheinlich noch wichtiger,
dass man irgendwie viele gute Freunde hat.
Und deswegen ist das nicht zu unterschätzen, diese ganzen diplomatischen Erfolge der Ukraine.
Im Kontrast zu den diplomatischen Erfolgen Russlands, die halt Nordkorea so auf ihrer Seite haben.
China, naja, ist wenigstens nicht gegen sie.
Auch nicht für sie. Aber auch nicht so richtig. China ist für China.
Und ja, weiß Russland. Und ja, das war es dann so fast schon.
Und noch so ein paar geputschte afrikanische Staaten, aber auch da wird es schwierig für Russland.
Jetzt mussten sie ihre Söldner sogar aus Mali abziehen und da wird auch gerüchtet,
dass das teilweise mit ukrainischem Einfluss abläuft.
Ja gut, dann schauen wir nochmal so ein bisschen das Verhältnis von USA und NATO.
Das läuft ja nicht so gut. Trump ist so on a wild rage und nutzt diesen ganzen
Iran-Krieg dazu, sich permanent irgendwie bei allen zu beklagen über mangelnde Unterstützung.
Kurz nachdem er gesagt hat, er brauche keine, dann hat Merz irgendwie zum Besten gegeben,
dass er seine Töchter nicht in die USA schicken wollen würde und ansonsten im
Irankrieg auch nicht teilnimmt, weil das ist alles doof,
woraufhin dann Trump gesagt hat, er würde dann jetzt 5000 Soldaten aus Deutschland abziehen.
Und kurz danach wollte er das irgendwie dann auch noch in Polen machen,
das wurde dann aber wieder rückgängig gemacht, also es ging irgendwie alles
wieder total diffus hin und her und das US-Militär, die müssen sich ja mittlerweile
auch fragen, wo noch oben ist.
Ja, also es war so, also die zweite Geschichte mit den 4000 Soldaten,
die nach Polen verlegt werden, nicht nur verlegt werden sollten,
sondern verlegt wurden.
Also deren Material war schon unterwegs, das war schon verladen und auf Schiffen
und auf Flugzeugen und so im Rahmen eben der routinemäßigen Truppenrotation.
Also es ist halt so, dass Einheiten dann eben nach Europa reinverlegt werden,
teilweise eine Zeit lang hier bleiben und dann wieder zurückverlegt werden.
Das ist halt ganz normal. Und ja, mit diesem Abzug von 5000 Soldaten aus Deutschland,
die offizielle Begründung war jetzt nicht, weil der März irgendwie so böse ist,
aber es kam halt zeitlich relativ kurz danach und wurde halt damit in Verbindung
gesetzt. Ich weiß nicht, ob...
Das jetzt einfach nur ein Anlass war, aber grundsätzlich so wurde ja befürchtet,
dass in der vorherigen Regierung, dass Trump wieder versuchen würde,
Truppen aus Europa abzuziehen, weswegen man dann danach der Kongress verabschiedet hatte,
dass die Untergrenze von 75.000 US-Soldaten in Europa aufrechterhalten werden muss.
Und zwar wurde das im National Defense Authorization Act, also im Prinzip da,
wo das Geld bewilligt wird,
wo das Geld unter der Bedingung bewilligt, dass halt 75.000 Soldaten mindestens
in Europa stationiert bleiben.
Die aktuellen Zahlen liegen irgendwie bei 65.000 bis 70.000,
die permanent hier sind.
Und wenn man jetzt noch die Rotationen und Übungen, kommt man irgendwie auf
80.000 bis 100.000 Soldaten.
Und interessant ist, dass auch niemand genau weiß, wie viele Soldaten eigentlich
in Europa sind, weil da so viel rotiert und gewechselt wird,
ändert sich das halt von Tag zu Tag eigentlich offenbar.
Und jetzt war dann die Frage, okay, wenn jetzt 5.000 Soldaten aus Deutschland
abgezogen werden, wohin gehen die dann?
Und der National Defense Authorization Act verlangt eigentlich,
dass sie in Europa bleiben, sodass dann vermutet wurde, dass sie halt stattdessen
vielleicht nach Rumänien gehen, statt nach Deutschland oder so.
Und ein Problem jetzt für die Amerikaner dabei ist,
oder generell für die gesamte Sicherheit, wenn die jetzt ganz abgezogen werden,
eine dieser Truppen ist halt wichtig für Flugabwehr.
Es ist halt ein Flugabwehrregal mit auch einem neuen System,
das ist ein Flugabwehrsystem, die dann stationiert werden sollten.
Und wenn die jetzt nicht kommen, sind natürlich die amerikanischen Basen in
Deutschland mehr gefährdet durch Luftschläge.
Also es ist jetzt irgendwie, für die Amerikaner ist das jetzt nicht gerade schlau,
also für die Sicherheit der US-Amerikaner, sich da so zu schwächen.
Aber es ist auch so, dass die meisten so in Deutschland stationiert sind,
allein mit Rammstein und so.
Also fast die Hälfte oder über ein Drittel jedenfalls aller Truppen in Europa,
US-Truppen in Europa sind in Deutschland stationiert. das.
Die Frage ist natürlich jetzt, wie geht es weiter mit USA und NATO?
Droht jetzt wirklich ein kompletter Ausstieg?
Mittlerweile nimmt ja niemand mehr wirklich an, dass in der aktuellen Situation,
die sich natürlich auch bald ändern kann, aber die Situation ist nochmal so, wie sie ist.
Ja, das, sagen wir mal, es würde jetzt wirklich, ist jetzt ein bisschen unwahrscheinlich,
aber würde es in irgendeiner Form einen richtigen Angriff geben,
damit meine ich jetzt nicht so eine Drohne verirrt sich nach Rumänien,
wie wir das jetzt letzte Woche auch hatten,
keine Ahnung, gezielter Raketenbeschuss Rumäniens, sowas.
Ja, könnte ja sein, dass die Russen sagen, ach ihr helft ja hier den Ukrainern,
da ballern wir mal irgendwie hier die nächstgelegende Großstadt ein paar Häuser weg.
Würde dann die USA irgendwas tun?
Rechnet, glaube ich, keiner so richtig damit. Und das ist ja schon schlimm genug.
Naja, es ist, ich meine, der, der, der, erst mal oder vielleicht noch mal einen Schritt zurück.
Ich meine, das Absurde an der ganzen Situation ist ja, dass NATO eigentlich
eine US-Veranstaltung wäre. Ja.
Ja, so, das heißt, das war jetzt nicht so, dass die Europäer jetzt irgendwann
mal gekommen wären und bei der USA angeklopft hätten und gesagt hätten,
na komm, lass uns doch mal ein Militärbündnis machen, sondern das war schon
relativ klar, ich sag mal,
Westalliierten und so und Lord Ismay, der dann berühmter gesagt hat, ja, NATO,
keep the Americans in and the Germans down and the Russians out.
Also das war der ursprüngliche Sinn und Zweck der NATO sehr pointiert zusammengefasst.
Und ja, also ich denke mal,
sehr viel von Trump ist eigentlich Gerede und es ist schon davon auszugehen,
dass ja, die USA hat halt Truppen hier, ist halt NATO.
Und ich denke mal nicht, dass die jetzt nicht reagieren würden in so einem Fall.
Aber die Frage ist natürlich, was glauben die Russen?
Oder das ist wichtiger, was denken eigentlich die Gegner, was die USA machen würde. und äh,
Das, was Trump tut, schwächt natürlich die Abschreckung, ganz klar.
Wenn du Frieden erhalten willst, dann willst du, dass dein Gegner glaubt,
ja, da ist nichts zu holen, weil wenn ich das versuche, dann ist das ziemlich übel.
Idealerweise sind so Abschreckungen durch Verweigerung, Also indem man halt
so viele Waffen hat, dass wenn Russland angreift, dass alles abgeschossen wird oder dann eben,
dass man so viele Vergeltungswaffen hat, dass wenn Russland das probiert,
irgendwie fünfmal so viel auf Russland niedergeht.
Das Erste ist natürlich zu bevorzugen, wenn Russland glaubt,
dass es seine eigenen Raketen gar nicht erst durchkriegt.
Und was Trump halt tut, ist einfach generell die Abschreckung zu schwächen.
Und Versagen der Abschreckung war ja auch die Grund für den Ausbruch des Ukraine-Kriegs,
weil Russland der Meinung war, sie können da schnell gewinnen.
Und selbe irgendwie mit Iran, da hat auch die Abschreckung offenbar versagt gegenüber Trump.
So da auch nicht damit gerechnet, dass das so umständlich werden würde.
Und ja, aber ich glaube, NATO ist nicht tot,
aber so definitiv auf dem absteigenden Ast und mittlerweile werden eben auch
durchaus parallel Infrastrukturen geschaffen für den Fall,
dass die Amerikaner sich vielleicht zurückziehen, was aber auch Trump nicht per Dekret machen kann,
sondern auch das würde eigentlich Kongress erfordern.
Aber der NATO-Vertrag, dieser Artikel 5, enthält ja nicht die Verpflichtung.
Irgendwas zu tun, sondern da wird dann ein Prozess ausgelöst,
da werden dann Konsultationen ausgelöst und jedes Land ist dann halt angehalten,
irgendwie einen Beitrag zu leisten.
Aber es steht jetzt, es ist nicht quantifiziert in irgendeiner Weise oder es
gibt keine Sanktionsmechanismen oder was auch immer, wenn irgendjemand keinen Beitrag macht,
Also im Grunde genommen ist die NATO, ist das Bekenntnis der Regierungen dazu, was zu tun.
Und das ist natürlich definitiv jetzt geschwächt durch Trump,
wobei er jetzt nicht gesagt hat, offen.
Nö, er würde jetzt nicht zur Hilfe kommen, Aber er hat es oft genug angedeutet.
Und vermutlich, aber meine Vermutung ist nicht wirklich vollständig ernst gemeint,
sondern das war auch wieder so Trump,
der halt redet und zwar perspektivisch sieht, dass die Europäer da ihr eigenes
sich selber kümmern sollen.
Ich meine, das ist ja seit Jahrzehnten auch Thema in den USA und im Grunde genommen
ist es durchaus begrüßenswert,
wenn die Europäer quasi mehr von ihrer eigenen Verteidigung in die Hand nehmen.
Das macht Sinn.
Also warum sollen die Amerikaner hier 100.000 Soldaten in Europa stationieren?
Das ist eigentlich nur historisch begründet, beziehungsweise zum Vorteil der
USA, damit sie halt ihre globale Machtprojektion ausüben können und sicherlich
auch zum Vorteil Europas.
Aber man hat dann gesagt, naja gut, die Amerikaner sind hier,
da brauchen wir dann selber auch nicht so viel zu tun, weil die Amerikaner es
einfach komplett übertreiben mit ihrer Rüstung und so.
Und ja, das war halt einfach attraktiv für beide Seiten. So nur...
Ja, nur eigentlich historisch ein bisschen unzeitgemäß wiederum.
Ich meine, dass die Amerikaner sich jetzt mit dem Verhalten von Trump selber
ins Fleisch schneiden, ist ja offensichtlich.
Und klar, Europa soll mehr tun für die eigene Verteidigung.
Okay, bin ich auch voll dabei. Frage ist, wie weit soll das jetzt gehen?
Man hat sich natürlich in gewisser Hinsicht ein bisschen ausgeruht,
durch diese totale militärische Supermacht musste man ja noch nicht mal alles abdecken.
Also man sieht das ja sowas, Patriot-System, gibt es halt irgendwie gar nichts anderes.
Bei Flugzeugen war es ja ähnlich, nicht dass Europa nicht in der Lage ist,
Flugzeuge zu bauen, sehen wir ja jetzt hier auch mit dem Gripen und es gab ja
immer schon Eurofighter und so weiter.
Aber so eine komplette militärische Systematik mit wie planen wir eigentlich
unsere Einsätze, welche logistischen Ressourcen haben wir und so weiter,
hat man sich natürlich schon sehr darauf verlassen, dass die USA jede Lücke
füllen und in den meisten Bereichen sozusagen ohnehin so dominant sind.
Weil sie halt eine der wenigen Länder überhaupt sind, die für so eine internationale
Flotte verfügen und eine internationale Logistikkette überhaupt aufbauen können.
Das können ja glaube ich, nehmen die Amerikaner, am bestenfalls mal noch die
Briten ein bisschen und die Franzosen.
Es gab halt eine klare Aufgabenteilung in der NATO.
Einfach nicht irgendwann mal dazu übergegangen, dass man gesagt hat,
nicht jedes Land braucht jede militärische Fähigkeit.
Gerade die kleineren Länder, was weiß ich, brauchst nicht irgendwie eine große
Marine und eine Luftwaffe und Landstreitkräfte in allen Ländern.
Varianten oder Fähigkeiten, sondern da hat man sich dann eben fokussiert und
eben auch konzentriert.
So sieht Estland jetzt im Bereich Cyber zum Beispiel.
Und die USA natürlich mit ihrem absolut übertriebenen Militärhaushalt von jetzt fast eine Milliarde.
US-Dollar und der dann auf anderthalb steigen soll, war immer doppelt so hoch wie der von.
Europa und Europa ist auch noch ein bisschen ineffizienter, hat ein bisschen
mehr Kaufkraft, weil Dinge auch billiger sind,
Aber so ungefähr sagen zwei Drittel USA, ein Drittel Europa und Europa eigentlich
will sich nur verteidigen.
Europa hatte bisher nicht den Anspruch, gut Frankreich und Großbritannien haben
halt noch ein bisschen Expeditionsfähigkeiten,
Aber ansonsten alle anderen Armeen oder Militärs in Europa sind in erster Linie dazu da,
das eigene Land zu verteidigen.
Und dafür brauchst du eigentlich auch weniger Militär, als wenn du jetzt vorhast, Russland zu erobern.
So, jetzt ist die Frage bei dem, okay, was tun wir irgendwie,
was für eine Art von Militär brauchen wir?
Und auf der einen Seite kann man sagen, eigentlich reicht uns eine Verteidigung,
reichen uns ausreichende Verteidigungsfähigkeiten, aber was macht man,
wenn jetzt sich Russland zusammenbricht
oder auseinanderbricht oder es irgendwie neue Konflikte gibt?
Also in welchem Ausmaß will man jetzt interventionsfähig sein?
Na gut, Russland will auf absehbare Zeit ein Problem bleiben.
Da kann man sich schon mal drauf konzentrieren.
Ich will jetzt nicht ewig noch über die NATO reden, aber was in diesem Zusammenhang
ja noch eine Diskussion, die jetzt noch aufkam, war halt sozusagen die Frage,
mit brauchen wir jetzt einen von der USA unabhängigen Atomschutzschild.
So, da gibt es ja im Prinzip mit Frankreich.
Eine Atommacht halt in der EU, die ja jetzt quasi diese Diskussion auch führt.
Und ja, ich denke mal, das ist durchaus ein Modell, was akzeptabel ist.
Ich meine, das wird natürlich...
Frankreich dann eine entsprechende Aufwertung geben, gar keine Frage,
aber wer soll es denn halt auch sonst leisten?
Ja, ich meine, mit den Atomwaffen halt, wie gesagt, auf der einen Seite,
also es ist meine Sicht der Dinge mittlerweile ist,
wahrscheinlich ist die beste Position eigentlich ein latenter Atomstaat zu sein,
wie die meisten europäischen Länder sind.
Also, wenn ich jetzt Kanzler wäre, beispielsweise, oder irgendwie Regierungschef
von einem anderen deutschen Land.
Ja, bitte dein Wahlprogramm jetzt.
Würde ich, ja. Ich würde,
in Deutschland die Forschung und Entwicklung rund um Nuklearwaffen so weit vorantreiben,
wie es im Rahmen des Atomwaffensperrvertrags,
zur Nichtverbreitung von Atomwaffen,
erlaubt ist.
Und die Grenze liegt darin, dass du halt, du darfst halt keine konkreten Atomwaffen entwickeln.
Auch nicht theoretisch. Du darfst aber...
Atomwaffensimulationen durchführen zu Forschungszwecken. Das heißt,
du kannst halt, solange Sinn und Zweck dieser Forschung nicht der Bau einer Atomwaffe ist,
dann kannst du aber beliebige Designs einfach mal testen, um zu sehen,
was denn passieren würde, wenn man so eine Atomwaffe hätte oder so.
Das würde ich halt vorantreiben und würde dann vielleicht auch dafür sorgen.
Dass dann Know-how und Material und so auch vorhanden sind.
Sind, aber nicht jetzt für den konkreten Bau einer Bombe, sondern nur für den
Fall, dass man mal Materialien bräuchte, die zufällig auch dann bei dem Bau einer Bombe helfen.
Und damit kann man dann ungefähr die,
die Zeit, wenn man denn eine Atombaffe braucht, auf ein paar Wochen reduzieren,
um eine Atombaffenproduktion zu starten.
Trägersysteme ist das andere Ding, aber in Deutschland werden sowieso,
glaube ich, Teile der französischen Atomraketen gebaut.
Oder zumindest unter deutscher Beteiligung.
So, also die Trägersysteme, da ist Deutschland mit dran beteiligt und insofern
die Technologie und das Know-how ist also auch dafür da.
Also mit anderen Worten, ich würde jetzt im Rahmen des Atomwaffensperrvertrags
bleiben erstmal und für den Fall, dass sich dann die Situation aber irgendwann dermaßen verschärft,
so kann man den Vertrag auch kündigen.
Ich glaube, zwei Monate Kündigungsfrist oder so.
Okay.
Ja, und dann kann man auch legal, könnte Deutschland legal Atomwaffen bauen und besitzen.
Und ich meine, das ist auch, was der Iran anstrebt. Der Iran will auch keine Atomwaffen bauen.
Er möchte eben nur die Möglichkeit haben für den Fall.
Gut, wenn man sich langsam fragen, okay, für welchen Fall eigentlich,
weil ist der Fall der Fälle nicht eigentlich schon eingetreten,
aber unabhängig davon. Also,
Das wäre das Ding mit ansonsten französischer Atomschild.
Es ist halt schwierig.
Also ein europäischer Atomschild wäre wahrscheinlich dann die Antwort.
Aber das würde dann wiederum erfolgen, dass man dafür bräuchte man dann auch
sowas wie eine europäische Regierung oder ein europäisches Militär und europäische Steuern und so.
Und es wird wahrscheinlich alles, also der Trend geht in die Richtung,
aber das wird potenziell Jahrzehnte dauern und ich hoffe eher,
dass dann Atomwaffen vielleicht abgerüstet werden.
Wir hatten ja oft schon die Debatte, dass sie auch, also sie sind nicht so nützlich, wie man glaubt.
In Afghanistan waren sie nutzlos, in Vietnam waren sie nutzlos,
im Irak waren sie nutzlos und Russ.
Und für Russland sind sie in der Ukraine jetzt weitgehend nutzlos.
So insofern ja also aber ja.
Gut lass uns zum Ende kommen und nochmal einen kleinen Ausblick wagen wie es
denn jetzt so weitergehen könnte und was wir erwarten oder was wir denken was passieren könnte,
Wie schon berichtet, sind wir jetzt in dieser Situation.
Russischer Vormarsch ist praktisch gestoppt. Also nicht jetzt wirklich eben
auf den letzten Meter genau, aber von einer breiten Offensive ist derzeit halt wenig zu spüren.
Sie wollen es natürlich, aber passieren tut jetzt gerade nicht viel wir sehen,
dass die Ukraine stärker wird militärisch, sie wird stärker durch mehr,
Freunde, wie wir das so schön formuliert haben heute, was kann jetzt passieren
was ist vor allem für Russland jetzt überhaupt noch eine Option, weil,
gewinnen, werden sie diesen Krieg nicht.
Und jetzt muss es halt irgendwie einen Way Out geben.
Jedenfalls so nicht.
Ja, so nicht und weil ich sehe ja jetzt auch ehrlich gesagt keine andere Option,
aber du hast ja ein paar Gedanken dazu gemacht.
Ja, wobei es nicht originär jetzt meine Gedanken alles sind,
sondern schon so kursieren, aber es gibt grundsätzlich,
man ist jetzt auch kein Rocket Science, aber es gibt im Wesentlichen vier Optionen.
Der erste ist, Russland akzeptiert die Niederlage,
bemüht sich ernsthaft um Verhandlungen, um einen Waffenstillstand und guckt so.
Ja, das hört damit auf.
Und handelt dann auch Sanction Relief dafür aus, also dass dann diese Sanktionen aufgehoben werden,
was dann die Wirtschaft zumindest von einem weiteren Verfall abhalten könnte
und dann wieder ins neues Ölgeld reinbringen könnte.
Aber so Putin würde ja ziemlich alt aussehen dabei.
Das ist das Problem und wahrscheinlich das Nicht-Überleben, wenn er das jetzt akzeptiert.
So, die zweite ist, es ist eigentlich...
Fast die wahrscheinlichste Variante, würde ich sagen, aus anderen Konflikten,
dass da eingefroren wird, der Konflikt.
Also, dass man einen Waffenstillstand vereinbart, aber auch nicht viel mehr.
Und ja, dass wir dann zu einer Situation kommen,
wo man bis vor 2022 war, dass man sich hier und da mal ein bisschen beschießt
und es hier und da noch Angriffe gibt.
Aber der große Krieg
dann erst mal vorbei ist und sich dann Russland erst mal versucht zu konsolidieren
und dann irgendwann nochmal versucht nachzuverhandeln oder so.
Aber ja, es würde aber sicherlich dann nicht dazu führen, dass Sanktionen aufgehoben werden oder so.
Das reine Einfrieren würde halt dann im Prinzip Fortsetzung eines kalten Konflikts.
Ja und ich meine, das Einfrieren ist ja jetzt in dem Sinne auch keine alleinige
Entscheidung Russlands, sondern die müsste ja dann auch die Ukraine zustimmen
und ich weiß nicht, ich habe nicht so das Gefühl, dass sie denkt,
dass das für sie überhaupt eine Option ist.
Ja, also da würde ich eher auch so ein bisschen, also einerseits ist das das,
was passiert, wenn beiden Seiten die Kraft ausgeht.
Also wenn beide Seiten gleichzeitig Kraft und Wille ausgehen,
wenn beide Seiten irgendwann feststellen, wir haben keinen Bock mehr,
aber eben auch keine Seite einfach irgendwie klein beigibt oder so.
Dass man dann sagt, Waffenstillstand und das war es dann.
Ich meine, Nord- und Südkorea, das ist heute im Kriegszustand.
Und haben auch nur einen Waffenstillstand und beschießen sich gegenseitig ab
und zu mal und bringen Leute um, schleusen Agenten ein, die Morde verüben.
Aber ich finde den Vergleich nicht so passend, weil das ja sozusagen nur die
Teilung eines Landes ist und nicht die Invasion eines anderen Landes.
Da gibt es diesen Kulturkampf nicht.
Ja, aber es gibt, also Konflikteinfrieren ist einfach das Einfachste.
Also von allen Varianten jetzt, wenn man nicht mehr weiterkämpfen kann.
Na gut.
Und sich aber auch nicht einigen kann, aus welchen Gründen auch immer. Ja,
so und ja, dann Option drei und vier wären dann, dass Russland einfach einen oben drauf legt.
Also Option, die dritte Option wäre dann halt Massenmobilmachung und ja,
mit allen Problemen, die wir beschrieben haben,
katastrophal für die Wirtschaft und Protestpotenzial und so und viele Leute
verstecken sich dann wieder in den Bäldern oder hauen in die Nachbarländer ab oder so.
Also insofern, ja, mit vielen Problemen behaftet.
Und das andere wäre, ja, eine drastische Eskalation.
Aber ich sehe da auch nicht mehr so viel Eskalationspotenzial,
was da ist. Und wenn das dann schief geht, dann war es das.
Wenn man irgendwie massive Eskalation versucht und alles rauswirft.
Ja, aber ich meine, das machen sie ja eigentlich schon die ganze Zeit.
Also diese Angriffe mit allem, was sie produzieren können, greifen sie die Ukraine alles auf einmal an.
Tausend Raketen, die da gleichzeitig ins Land segeln.
Das ist ja jetzt nicht steigerungsfähig.
Naja, sie haben Reserven.
Also die werden zwar nicht größer, aber sie haben halt auch noch Soldaten anderswo
im Land, die andere Grenzen beschützen zum Beispiel und andere Dinge tun.
Sie könnten schon nochmal jetzt von überall, klar haben sie schon teilweise
gemacht, dass sie von überall was abgezogen haben, aber da ginge noch mehr.
Ja gut, aber sie müssen diese reine Soldatenzahl alleine, reicht ja nicht,
weil diese Soldaten brauchen Waffen, diese Soldaten brauchen die Logistik,
sie brauchen die Versorgung, sie brauchen Geld und das ist ja jetzt alles schon dünn.
Also ich sehe ja nicht, jetzt schon nicht, dass sie in der Lage sind,
überhaupt noch das zu leisten, was sie brauchen für den derzeitigen Druck, den sie ausüben.
Mit mehr Leuten ist da nicht viel gewonnen. Die werden dann einfach nur mehr umgebracht.
Ja, sie könnten natürlich,
versuchen, irgendwie nochmal wieder
zu, ich sag mal, sowas wie Flächenbombardements oder so durchzuführen.
Also es ist nicht, es ist schon so, dass die Russen grundsätzlich versuchen,
auch militärische Ziele zu bekämpfen.
Es gelingt ihnen halt nur nicht so gut und deswegen plus, dass es ihnen nichts
ausmacht oder dass es dann oft einfacher ist,
zivile Ziele zu bekämpfen oder man glaubt, das seien militärische Ziele oder
wie auch immer, aber so Russland könnte schon jetzt sagen,
versuchen, also ich glaube, Also Russland versucht nicht gezielt,
möglichst viele ukrainische Zivilisten zu töten.
Weil es käme halt auch nicht gut an und nützt halt relativ wenig.
Es kommt ja derzeit schon nicht gut an und es nützt auch derzeit relativ wenig.
Man kann sich jetzt über die Zahl streiten, aber dass das ja genau stattfindet, das wissen wir auch.
Jetzt können wir sagen, es könnte ja noch mehr sein, aber ich sehe dieses mehr nicht.
Ich denke, dass Russland derzeit schon in seinem Maximum angekommen ist.
Nicht an dem Maximum, was es theoretisch leisten könnte, aber an dem Maximum,
was es praktisch leisten kann in diesem Krieg.
Was man bereit ist, sozusagen,
da rein zu werfen und das ist schon, ja, das ist schon eine ganze Menge,
aber eben nicht alles. Das ist meine Sicht.
Also ich habe so Zweifel, dass dann das Land da auch in dem Maße mitgehen würde
und dass das alles so gut funktionieren würde, dass es auch wirklich stattfinden kann.
Gut. Lassen Sie sich so ewig darüber reden, das sind, sagen wir mal,
so ein bisschen auch so die Optionen aus Putins Perspektive.
Ich finde ja, Niederlage klingt dabei eigentlich am besten so,
dann ist er zwar abgesägt, aber das ist eigentlich das Einzige,
was hier wirklich hilft.
Ich denke, langfristig läuft es auch darauf hinaus.
Vielleicht nochmal ganz kurz zum Schluss so aus ukrainischer Perspektive.
Ich denke, dass derzeit die,
Also die Moral im Lande ist immer unter Druck. Wir dürfen nicht vergessen,
täglich Angriffe, permanentes Leben im Krieg, das macht die Leute auch depressiv.
Jeden Tag sterben auch viele ukrainische Soldaten und Zivilisten.
Das macht was mit so einem Land und das ist natürlich alles nicht gut.
Trotzdem glaube ich, dass diese Resilienz der Ukraine selbst weitgehend ungebrochen ist.
Das heißt, die werden sich Russland so lange entgegenstellen, bis die weg sind.
Und ich denke auch, dass in dem Moment, wo solche Dynamiken sich jetzt freisetzen,
wie wir das jetzt sehen, dass die Ukraine sogar in der Lage ist,
ein Übergewicht zu machen.
Und ich halte es auch für durchaus wahrscheinlich, dass sie in der Ukraine Patriot-ähnliche
Systeme entwickelt bekommen.
Da arbeiten sie unter Garantie dran, schon lange.
Und wann es ihnen gelingen wird, kann ich nicht sagen. Es ist schwierig,
aber es ist nicht unmöglich.
Sie haben ja auch andere Probleme technisch gelöst und sie haben diesen konkreten
Bedarf und dieser Bedarf wird immer der stärkste Treibstoff sein.
Sie haben jetzt offiziell ja bei den Amerikanern um eine Lizenz angefragt für
die Herstellung von Patriot-Raketen.
Für die Raketen, nicht für die Systeme an sich. Die Systeme haben sie ja,
es geht ihnen ja nur um die Raketen, aber ich glaube, da wird sich Trump dem
genauso widersetzen wie allem anderen auch.
Und deswegen ist die einzige Konsequenz, dass sie eben noch mehr daran arbeiten
werden, dort ihre eigenen Lösungen zu finden.
Und die werden sie auch finden. Wann vermag ich nicht zu sagen,
das kann noch eine Weile dauern, bis dahin wird es halt weiterhin schwierig bleiben.
Aber wenn man sich andere Trends anschaut, nämlich, dass sie jetzt die Russen
aufhalten können, dass sie die Russen die Logistik zerhauen kann,
das kann schon auch dazu führen,
dass sich mittelfristig diese Front auflöst, dass die Russen zumindest Teile opfern müssen.
Und der erste Teil der...
Der Fallen würde, der am schwächsten ist, der am schwierigsten zu verteidigen
ist für die Russen, ist halt die Krim.
Also Donbass und so weiter, wo sie sozusagen auf breiter Front mit ihren eigenen
Ländern dahinter liegen und schon seit zehn Jahren zu Hause sind.
Das ist vielleicht wirklich nur noch durch Verhandlungen auszulösen.
Aber der südliche Teil von Kherson und die Krim, die ist halt militärisch sehr
vulnerabel, weil die einfach ein Versorgungsproblem haben.
Versorgung mit Wasser ist knapp, die Versorgung mit Treibstoff jetzt ist knapp.
Die Brücke alleine reicht da nicht und wenn dieser Teil so ab Saporizia nach
Kherson abgeschnitten werden kann,
dann denke ich mal, würde sich das Platz schnell drehen, denn die Krim ist hier die heilige Kuh.
Das ist nicht nur irgendwie so ein Stück Land.
Donbass und so weiter, das ist den Russen eigentlich relativ egal.
Die Krim allerdings ist so das totale Symbol.
Als sich Putin die Krim geschnappt hat, da war das super populär in diesem Land.
Und wenn die Krim fallen würde, würde damit glaube ich auch jegliche Unterstützung
für diesen Krieg fallen. Das würden sie einfach nicht überleben.
Und von daher kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass das ein Ziel ist.
Dass das sozusagen der Plan ist, der Ukraine alles dafür zu tun,
diesen Teil so abzuschneiden, um dort wirklich zu Ergebnissen zu kommen.
Die Ukraine hat die Krim umringt, es wird von überall mit Drohnen angegriffen,
es wird permanent die Luftverteidigung dort geschwächt und die Tanklager aufgelöst.
Also es wird eigentlich die ganze Zeit daran gearbeitet, diesen Teil so sehr
zu schwächen, dass er eben auch ablösbar ist und ich halte das jetzt nicht für
wahrscheinlich, dass das jetzt irgendwie morgen passiert,
aber ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das eigentlich der Schlüssel zum Erfolg ist.
Wenn das gelingt, dann ist alles möglich.
Ja, also nur meine Sicht der Dinge und ich nicht nur meine, sondern ich habe
die auch vielfach anderswo gehört.
Derzeit ist keiner der beiden Parteien auch nur ansatzweise in der Lage,
in einen Bewegungskrieg überzugehen.
Also dazu müsstest du halt massiv Fahrzeuge, Panzer massieren und dann einen
Durchbruch mit Luftunterstützung und so.
Und bei einfach der aktuellen
Drohnendichte und dem Mangel einer wirklich zuverlässigen Drohnenabwehr kannst
du einfach nicht genug Truppen massieren.
Also keine Seite kann genug Kräfte konzentrieren, ohne sie gleichzeitig eben
massiven Angriffen dann auszusetzen.
Das ist das Problem. Und um dahin zu kommen, ja,
wenn Ukraine oder mit Hilfe des Westens jetzt das Thema Drohnenabwehr irgendwie
knackt, oder es wäre so ein Ding, wenn sie in der Lage sind,
wirklich komplett sämtliche russischen Drohnen im Umkreis von 50 Kilometern auszuschalten.
Und die am Fliegen zu hindern, dann wäre es möglich, Truppen zu massieren und
dann wäre es möglich, eventuell einen Durchbruch und einen Vormarsch zu erzielen.
Die andere Variante wäre noch, wenn einfach die Russen an der Front verhungern
und selber einfach die Front räumen,
weil es nichts mehr zu essen gibt.
Dort, also das wäre die andere Variante, die einfach gewissermaßen auszuhungern
und sie keine Munition und keine Waffen und keine Drohnen mehr haben,
dann das wäre die andere Variante.
Ja, aber derzeit sieht es nicht so aus, dass irgendeine Seite jetzt in absehbarer
Zeit in diese Position gelangen könnte.
Gut, du machst deinem Ruf alle Ehre am Schluss dann immer den optimistischen
Ausblick zu unterwandern.
Ich bin da durchaus optimistischer gestimmt, aber wir werden es sehen,
wir werden es verfolgen und wir werden es berichten hier für euch.
Jetzt machen wir erstmal hier den Sack zu. Wir haben jetzt sehr lange geredet.
Ich hoffe, ihr habt da zu Ende hören können und seid noch mit dabei.
Ich hoffe, dass wir die nächsten Updates nicht so lange rauszögern werden.
Mal gucken, wie sich das jetzt entwickelt.
Passiert ja gefühlt derzeit eine Menge, aber jetzt kommt auch so ein bisschen
der Sommer mit den damit verbundenen Pausen. Deswegen weiß ich noch nicht so ganz genau.
Wir schauen uns dann mal das Ukraine-Museum an, würde ich mal vorschlagen, die Tage.
Und ihr könnt das ja auch gerne tun, wenn ihr mal in Berlin seid.
Das ist auf jeden Fall zu empfehlen.
Ja, und dann würde ich sagen, sagen wir Tschüss.
Vielleicht noch einen positiven Satz. Ach, dann doch.
Dann mal los.
Ja, ja, ich sag mal unter allen Bedingungen, unter den gesamten,
politischen Rahmenbedingungen, keine Hilfe aus den USA, übermächtiger Gegner.
So ist das, was die Ukraine leistet, nach wie vor brillant und gibt halt Anlass zur Hoffnung.
Auf jeden Fall. Gut. Damit enden wir jetzt die Sendung. Das ist gut. On a high note.
Leute, vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Das war es von uns. Wir sagen Tschüss und bis bald.
Tschüss.